Mọi người đều nhìn thấy màn hình của
mình rồi đúng không? Hôm nay chúng ta
bắt đầu buổi thứ hai các bạn nhá. Hôm
qua chúng ta đang dừng lại ở cái đoạn
chúng ta nói về các cái loại dữ liệu
đúng không? Dữ liệu trong AI, trong data
trong machining chúng ta sẽ chia ra làm
hai loại. Cái loại đầu tiên là cái dữ
liệu gốc ban đầu dữ liệu thô ấy ta gọi
là unlel data hay là dữ liệu chưa được
đánh nhãn đúng không? Dữ liệu không được
đánh nhãn. Thế còn cái loại thứ hai là
gì? Là sau cái quá trình mà chúng ta
ngồi chúng ta đánh nhãn dữ liệu rồi đúng
không? Có một ai đấy người ta ngồi người
ta đánh nhãn cho rượu rồi thì nó sẽ chỉ
đánh rượu có đánh nhãn đúng không? Thì
cái quá trình này người ta gọi là data
annotation hay là data labeling.
Ờ ở Việt Nam mình thì có rất nhiều công
ty làm về cái bản ảnh nhãn dữ liệu này.
Việt Nam, Trung Quốc và các cái nước ở
châu Phi là các cái nước mà có cái Việt
Nam, Trung Quốc, Ấn Độ và các cái nước ở
châu Phi là cái nước mà có cái thị
trường về đánh nha dữ liệu nó rất là rất
là phát triển tại vì chúng ta có chi phí
nhân công giá rẻ.
Đấy. Và hôm qua chúng ta nói gì? Tức là
rượu không được đánh nhãn là rượu mà có
rất là nhiều đúng không? Còn rượu đánh
nhãn này nó ít tại vì là nó cần phải có
con người can thiệp vào. Thế thế hôm nay
chúng ta sẽ sang phần tiếp theo. Chúng
ta sẽ nói về ờ cách phân loại các cái
thuật toán trong machining.
Ờ hôm qua chúng ta nói rồi, chúng ta nói
là machining là các cái là cái hướng
tiếp cận và chúng ta sẽ huấn luyện mô
hình theo cách là không tường minh. Tức
là chúng ta sẽ không cần phải chỉ ra rõ
ràng xem là thế nào là email spam, thế
nào là email bình thường, thế nào là
dịch lừa đảo, thế nào là dịch bình
thường đúng không? Ch đưa rượu vào rồi
mô hình nó sẽ học cái mối quan hệ giữa
đầu vào với đầu ra để nó tự đợi quyết
định của mình đúng không? Thì trong
machining ấy trong machining nó có rất
nhiều nó có rất nhiều các cái thuật toán
khác nhau và cũng có rất nhiều cách để
có thể phân loại các cái thuật toán này
thành các cái nhóm khác nhau. Thế nhưng
mà một trong số những cách phổ biến phải
được sử dụng rộng rãi nhất là gì? Là
người ta sẽ phân loại các cái thuật toán
trong machining dựa theo phương thức
học. Phân lại các cái thuật toán trong
machining dựa theo phương thức học.
Thế thì nếu mà phân loại giữa giữa
phương thức học ấy thì người ta sẽ phân
các cái thuật toán trong mơ sinh ra làm
ba loại chính. Loại đầu tiên là
supervised learning hay là học có đám
sát. Loại thứ hai là unsupervised
learning hay là học không có đám sát. Và
loại thứ ba là reinforcement learning
hay tiếng Việt mình gọi là học tăng
cường nhá. Học có giám sát, học không có
giám sát và học tăng cường.
Thế thì cái sự khác biệt giữa ba cái
mảng nó như thế nào? Thì các bạn chú ý
này, với cái mảng đầu tiên ấy là
Supervis learning. Tất cả các cái thuật
toán trong mảng supervisarning này chúng
ta sẽ đều cần phải huấn luyện chúng với
dữ liệu được đánh nhãn hay là label data
là cái loại dữ liệu mà mà tốn kém cần
phải có cần phải có con người can thiệp
vào đấy đúng không? Thì chúng ta sẽ cần
phải huấn luyện các tố toán này với rượu
có đánh nhãn. Cái loại thứ hai là
learning này thì các cái thuật toán
trong ấy thì chúng ta sẽ huấn luyện
trúng với dữ liệu không được đánh nhãn
nhá. không được nhãn là cái loại rượu mà
nhiều mà rẻ đấy mà xung quanh chúng ta
đều có đấy đúng không? Đây là ăn
[khịt mũi] ăn unsur learning đúng không?
Supervice là với label data còn unsv là
với unlabel data. Còn cái loại thứ ba là
reinforcement learning thì tí nữa mình
sẽ nói tí nữa mình sẽ nói xem nó là cái
gì nhá. Thế thì thông thường ấy trong
các cái chương trình mà các bạn học về
AI, về data về machining các thứ ấy thì
thông thường các bạn sẽ dành phần lớn
thời gian để các bạn có thể học và tìm
hiểu về các cái thuật toán học của sát.
Và sau này các bạn đi làm, các bạn cũng
sẽ dành ph lớn thời gian để các bạn làm
việc với những thu toán như vậy. Thế còn
các cái thuật toán học không có sát thì
cái tần suất các bạn làm việc nó sẽ ít
hơn và các bạn sẽ dành ít thời gian cho
chúng hơn. Thế còn cái mảng thứ ba là
mảng reinforcement learning thì cái mảng
này gần như là gần như là ở gần như là ở
Việt Nam nó là tuyệt trục. Mảng reforce
learning này thì gần như là các bạn sẽ
các bạn sẽ không
các bạn sẽ không thấy là có cái job nào
ở cái mảng này. Không thấy có cái job
nào của cái mảng này. Đấy. Thế là bây
giờ chúng ta sẽ đi sâu vào từng mảng cụ
thể. Đi sâu vào từng mảng cụ thể nhá.
Đầu tiên cái mảng đầu tiên là supervised
learning là cái mảng mà chúng ta sẽ huấn
luyện về mô hình với dữ liệu có đánh
nhãn. Đó. Thế thì trong cái mảng này thì
người ta sẽ chia các cái thuật toán ra
làm hai cái nhánh con. một cái nhánh là
hai cái nhánh con này nó sẽ phụ thuộc
vào nó sẽ phục vụ cho hai bài toán chính
của SP learning. Cái nhánh đầu tiên là
các cái thuật toán dành cho các bài toán
re và cái nhánh thứ hai là dành cho các
cái bài toán liên quan đến
classification.
Reestion với cả classification thì nó
khác nhau ở chỗ nào?
Region với cả classification nó khác ở
chỗ là với regression ấy thì cái target
mà mô hình cần phải dự đoán ấy nó sẽ là
những cái giá trị nằm trong một cái giải
liên tục và nó sẽ có vô số giá trị khác
nhau. Ví dụ ví dụ các bạn đang sử dụng
cái mô hình để dự đoán nhiệt độ ngoài
trời. Nhiệt độ ngoài chơi đúng không? Ví
dụ nhiệt độ ngoài trời nó có thể là ờ
25°ộ, 25,1°ộ, 25,2°ộ, 25,3°ộ vân vân
đúng không? Thì đấy các bạn thấy không?
các cái giá trị mà các bạn mô hình cần
phải dự đoán ấy là những cái giá trị nằm
trong một cái giải liên tục đúng không?
Và các bạn sẽ có vô số giá trị khác
nhau. Các bạn sẽ không đếm được xem là
các bạn sẽ không đếm được xem là
có bao nhiêu giá trị đúng không? Thế thế
còn cái mảng thứ hai, cái cái bài toán
thứ hai là bài toán classification.
classification ấy thì cái thứ mà m cần
phải dự đoán ấy nó sẽ là một cái giá trị
nằm nó sẽ là những cái giá trị có hữu
hạn giá trị khác nhau và các bạn có thể
đếm được xem là có bao nhiêu. Ví dụ các
bạn sẽ dụng mô hình để phân loại xem
email có phải email spam hay không đúng
không? Email có phải email spam hay
không? Thì các bạn thấy không? Thì cái
đầu ra nó chỉ có hai giá trị thôi là
spam với cả không đúng không? Hoặc các
bạn sử dụng cái mô hình để
phân loại xem là một cái giây cái dây
lừa đảo hay không. nó chỉ có hai giá trị
thôi là lừa đảo hay là không đúng không?
Đấy thì nếu mà bài toán request ấy là nó
sẽ dự đoán những cái thứ ví dụ như là
nhiệt độ ngoài trời này, giá nhà này,
mức lương này đúng không? Là những cái
giá trị mà trong một cái giải liên tục
và nó có vô số giá trị các bạn không đếm
được cụ thể thêm là có bao nhiêu giá trị
khác nhau. Thế còn với classification
các bạn đếm được đúng không? Ví dụ các
bạn sẽ cái mô hình phân loại ảnh chó mèo
lợn gà nó chỉ có bốn giá trị thôi. Sự mô
hình để phân loại email spam hay không
nó chỉ có hai giá trị thôi. Sự mô hình
để phân loại xem người có bị bệnh hay
không nó cũng chỉ có hai giá trị thôi
đúng không? Thì đấy là cái sự phân biệt
giữa re với classification. Thì cả hai
cái đều là dữ liệu có đánh nhãn đúng
không? Cả hai đều là dữ liệu có đánh
nhãn. Thế nhưng nó chỉ khác biệt là một
ông là cái nhãn đấy là liên tục và có vô
số giá trị còn một bên là cái nhãn rời
giảm và có hữu hạn giá trị.
Thế
đây là request và classification. Có
những cái có những cái thuật toán có
những cái thuật toán nó chỉ phục vụ một
cho
các bạn cho mình xin phép 30 giây nhá.
Cho mình xin phép 30 giây nhá. Mình xin
phép một chút nhá.
Ok, rất là sorry các bạn nhá. Sorry các
bạn nha. Tiếp nhá. Đấy, thế đ là đấy là
cái sự khác biệt giữa ờ giữa bài toán
classification và bài toán reaction. Thế
thì sau này các bạn sẽ học thì các bạn
thấy là có những thuật toán nó chỉ phục
vụ bài toán regression thôi. Có những
thự toán nó phụ bài toán classification
và có những thư toán nó phục vụ cả hai
bài toán. Thì những cái buổi sau khi
chúng ta đi sâu vào cái thán này chúng
ta sẽ cùng nhau phân tích. Đấy nhưng mà
hiện tại các bạn biết là trong super
valing người ta chia ra làm hai cái
nhánh như vậy regression và
classification.
Và phần lớn thời gian các bạn học về
machining, các bạn sẽ học những cái
thuật toán như thế này. Các bạn sẽ học
những thu toán là supervise learning học
về rượu có đinh nhãn. Đấy đây là cái
nhánh thứ nhất. Cái nhánh thứ hai là
unvised learning. Unser learning là
những thuật là những cái thuật toán học
không có sát. Nhưng toán này chúng ta sẽ
làm việc với dữ liệu mà ờ không được
đánh nhãn. Không được đánh nhãn. Thế thì
trong answer learning ấ chúng ta sẽ phân
chia ra làm hai cái nhánh con, hai cái
bài toán con. Một là clustering và hai
là association.
Classing là
clustering là
classing là học là toán học phân cụm.
Classing là học cái toán nó liên quan
đến phân cụ. Phân cụm có nghĩa là gì?
Tức là cái nhiệm vụ của cái bài toán
clwing tức là chúng ta sẽ phải phân chia
các cái điểm dữ liệu này vào
k nhóm khác nhau sao cho các cái điểm dữ
liệu trong cùng một nhóm nó sẽ tương
đừng nhau và trong khi các cái dữ liệu
của điểm của cái nhóm này và cái nhóm
kia nó sẽ khác biệt nhau. Đấy là ý tưởng
của clusting. Ví dụ clustering chúng ta
phân ra làm ba nhóm chẳng hạn. nó phân
ra làm ba nhóm chẳng hạn thì
các cái thì cái mục tiêu của là nó sẽ
phân cái dữ liệu ra thành ba cái nhóm ba
cái cụm sao cho mà xem vột thô cục cụ
thì nó giống nhau. Sê bụ cụ này và sư bụ
cụ kia nó sẽ khác nhau. Thế là bài toán
đầu tiên clustering. Thì cái clustering
đấy nhìn qua nhìn qua một chút thì cái
clustering này nó sẽ hao hao giống với
nó sẽ hao hao giống với bài toán
bài toán classification. Tại vì sao? Tại
vì là cả class doanh việ cả
classification ấy cái nhiệm vụ là gì? là
đều phân dữ liệu ra thành ca nhóm đúng
không? Ví dụ là với bài toán
classification thì nó cũng tương đương
với việc gì là các bạn ví dụ là với
email spam chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì cái
bài toán classification nó cũng tương
đương việc là các bạn phân dữ liệu ra
thành hai nhóm. Một nhóm là email spam
và một nhóm là 0 đúng không? Tức là đây
k nó bằng 2. Thế còn cling nó cũng tương
tự như vậy. Ví dụ các bạn để k các bạn
phân ra thành hai cụm chẳng hạn thì nó
cũng tống tương tự như vậy. Tức là về
mặt gọi là về mặt giao diện thì hai bài
toán này nó đều có chung một cái mục
đích là gì? là phân rượu ra thành ca
nhóm khác nhau. Các cái sôi cùng nhóm
giống nhau, C1 nhóm này với s nhóm kia
nó khác nhau. Thế nhưng mà nó khác nhau
ở cái điểm gì? Nó khác nhau ở một cái
điểm là một ông là với rượu có đánh
nhãn, một ông là với rượu không được
đánh nhãn. Thế thì cái đánh nhãn không
đánh nhãn nó sẽ khác nhau ở cái gì? Thì
nó sẽ khác nhau ở cái việc là chúng ta
sẽ giải thích kết quả như thế nào? Mình
sẽ lấy cho bạn một cái ví dụ nhá. Mình
lấy cho bạn một cái ví dụ này. Các bạn
tưởng tượng này, cái việc mà chúng ta
huấn luyện mô hình ấy, bất kể là mô hình
si hay là ăn siovi ấy thì nó cũng không
khác gì cái là cái việc chúng ta dạy một
đứa trẻ học đúng không? chúng ta huấn
luyện mô hình bất kể là cái dạng gì thì
nó cũng giống như là chúng ta đang huấn
luyện một cái dạy một cái đứa trẻ vậy.
Thế bây gi các bạn cứ t các bạn cứ tưởng
tượng nhá.
Bây giờ á bây giờ ấy chúng ta
có một đứa trẻ nó mới 2 ba tuổi đúng
không? Bây giờ chúng ta sẽ dạy nó cách
để nó có thể phân loại các cái loại đồ
chơi với nhau. Thì bây giưởng tượng là
bây giờ các bạn ra cái tiệm Lego các bạn
mua rất là nhiều đồ chơi về đúng không?
Các bạn mua rất là nhiều đồ chơi về. Hôm
nay các bạn muốn dạy đứa trẻ nó phân
biệt giữa đồ chơi các cái hình dạng của
đồ chơi đúng không? hình vuông, hình
tròn với hình tam giác. Các bạn sẽ mua
rất nhiều đồ chơi về và đem nó có rất
nhiều những cái hình thù về các bạn đem
về đúng không? Rồi các bạn sẽ dạy cái
đứa trẻ này nó cách phân biệt đồ chơi
bằng cách nào các bạn? Các bạn sẽ lấy ra
trong cái túi đồ chơi là các bạn lấy ra
từng món nhá. Các bạn cứ lấy từng một
món sau các bạn sẽ show cái món đồ chơi
đấy ra trước mặt đứa trẻ rồi các bạn hỏi
nó là đây là hình gì đúng không? Thì cái
việc mà các bạn đưa cái món đồ chơi ra
trước đứa trẻ ấy nó cũng giống việc là
các bạn đang đưa rượu cho mô hình đấy.
Các bạn bắt mô hình phải dự đoán xem đây
là hình gì đúng không? Thế bây giờ đứa
trẻ nó sẽ bảo là đây là hình tam giác
chẳng hạn. Thì nếu mà đúng đây hình tam
giác các bạn bảo ừ đúng rồi. Còn nếu mà
đây không phải hình tam giác thì các bạn
bảo không phải đây không phải tam giác
đây là hình vuông chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như
vậy thì cái việc mà các bạn phản hồi lại
cho nó chính là việc các bạn đang đưa
cái nhãn vào để các bạn so sánh đấy đúng
không? Các bạn đang so sánh cái dự đoán
của mô hình với cả cái giá trị thực tế
đấy đúng không? Thì đứa trẻ nó nó bảo
đây là hình tam giác thì các bạn sẽ bảo
nó là đúng đây hình tam giác hoặc là
không phải đây không phải hình tam giác
đúng không? Thì cái việc mà các bạn nói
cho đứa trẻ biết ấy nó chính là cái nhãn
của dữ liệu đúng không? Sau cái quá
trình cứ lập đi lại như vậy t gì các bạn
cứ đưa nó một cái món đồ chơi nó bảo xem
đây là đồ chơi hình gì sau các bạn sẽ
bảo nó là đúng rồi hay là sai rồi cứ đ
lại như vậy thì quá trình này nó sẽ
giống như quá trình chúng ta đang huấn
luyện một cái mô hình dành cho bài toán
classification đúng không cái miếng lego
nó là nó là nó là data đúng không và cái
việc mà các bạn t các bạn phản hồi xem
là đây là đồ chơi gì thì nó chính là cái
nhãn của cái data đó đúng không nếu
không có cái phản hồi của bạn thì đây là
dữ liệu không được nhãn nhưng mà có phản
hồi của bạn thì đó là dữ liệu được đình
nhãn đúng không thì đấy là quá trình
chúng ta hỗ lệ Lượng một mô hình
classification và sau khi các bạn huấn
luyện nó rồi sau này thì nó các bạn có
thể đem cái đứa trẻ đi đến nhà bạn chơi
đúng không? Đứa bạn bè các bạn nó test
đứa trẻ đấy thì đứa trẻ nó sẽ có thể khả
năng nó phân biệt đồ chơi nó có thể chỉ
ra là cái món đồ chơi này là hình tam
giác món này là hình vuông món này là
hình tròn đúng không? Thì đấy là bài
toán classification.
Thế còn bài toán clustering nó như nào?
Bài toán clustering nó như này. Tức là
bây giờ các bạn vẫn mang đồ chơi về. Thế
nhưng mà bây giờ các bạn sẽ yêu cầu đứa
trẻ là gì? là hãy phân đồ chơi ra làm ba
nhóm khác nhau. Thế thôi các bạn chỉ bảo
nó là gì? Hãy phân đồ chơi ra làm ba
nhóm khác nhau. Thế thôi, xong các bạn
đi ra ngoài, các bạn không ở đấy các bạn
giúp nó thì nó sẽ phải tự bơi đúng
không? Nó sẽ phải tự ngồi nó sắp xếp đồ
chơi thì nó sẽ phân chia đồ chơi ra làm
ba nhóm khi mà sau sau khi mà nó thấy là
gì? Những cái món nào mà nó giống nhau
cái điểm gì đấy nó cho vào một nhóm đúng
không? Những cái điểm khác nhau thì nó
cho vào các nhóm khác nhau. Thế thì đến
cuối ấ đứa trẻ nó vẫn phân đồ chơi ra
làm ba nhóm. Thế nhưng ba cái nhóm này
ấy nó có
đúng là ba cái nhóm khác nhau về mặt
hình dạng hay không thì chúng ta không
biết đúng không? Nếu may mắn đứa trẻ nó
hiểu đúng cái ý của bạn đúng không? Nó
có thần do cái cảm với các bạn chẳng hạn
nó hiểu đúng cái ý bạn thì nó sẽ phân
chia ra làm theo hình dạng. Thế nhưng mà
thế nhưng mà cũng có thể là đứa trẻ nó
sẽ phân chia theo màu sắc. Phân chia
theo màu sắc có nghĩa là gì? Tức là màu
đỏ nó cho vào một nhóm, ờ màu xanh nó
cho vào một nhóm, ờ màu vàng nó cho vào
một nhóm đúng không? hoặc là nó lại phân
chia theo chất liệu tức là gì? Đồ bằng
gỗ nó cho vào một nhóm, đồ nhựa nó cho
vào một nhóm, đồ cao su cho vào một nhóm
đúng không? Thật ra là chúng ta sẽ không
bao giờ biết là cái ý nghĩa của từng
nhóm là cái gì tại vì đơn giản là chúng
ta không cho nó cái nhãn đúng không?
Chúng ta không ngồi đấy, chúng ta chỉ
cho nó là làm theo cái gì nên là nó sẽ
chỉ phân chia làm sao những cái đồ chơi
trong cùng nhóm thì giống nhau. Đồ chơi
nhóm này và đồ chơi nhóm kia nó khác
nhau thôi. Còn chúng ta không ai biết cụ
thể là nó phân chia theo cái tiêu chí
gì. Thì đấy là cái sự khác biệt của
clustering về classification. Cái
classification các bạn có thể chỉ ra là
mỗi nhóm có ý nghĩa gì tại vì các bạn có
nhãn. Còn classing các bạn không chỉ ra
được. Các bạn chỉ biết là các bạn có ca
nhóm khác nhau thôi. Còn cụ thể ý nghĩa
của từng nhóm thì không ai biết. Đấy là
sự khác biệt giữa classification và
cling. Và nó chính là cái sự khác biệt
giữa giá trị của dữ liệu có đánh nhãn và
dữ liệu không được đánh nhãn nhá. Đây là
bài toán clustering. Thế còn bài toán
nữa. Bài toán thứ hai trong cái mảnging
đó là bài toán bài toán phân cụ. À chư
các bạn các bạn nó là bài toán bài toán
association. Bài toán association các
bạn tí. Ok
bạn hỏi đi.
>> Dạ cho em hỏi là nếu vậy thì cái trong
cái thuật toán clustering á thì làm sao
để mà mình hướng dẫn cho nó phân theo
đúng cái ý của mình được ạ?
>> Không có cách nào cả. Thế nó mới gọi là
không có nhãn. Thế nó mới gọi là không
có nhãn. Nếu mà các bạn cho chỉ dẫn rồi
thì nó hành dữ liệu có đánh nhãn rồi
đúng không? Nếu các bạn có nếu các bạn
có chỉ dẫn là đây là cái món gì
[hắng giọng]
thế? Nếu mục đích của thật toán này là
để làm gì?
>> Cái gì cơ?
>> Dạ ý em là nếu vậy thì mục đích của cái
thuật toán clustering này sinh ra là để
làm gì?
>> Để nó phân dữ liệu thành các cái nhóm
tương đồng nhau. Thế thôi.
[hắng giọng]
Mục đích đó là để phân rượu ra các nhóm
tương đồng nhau.
Đấ.
Rồi tiếp nhá. Thế cái bài toán thứ hai
trong cái mảng answer learning ấ đó là
bài toán association. Bài toán
association bài toán này là bài toán kết
hợp. [hắng giọng]
Thế thế trong bài toán kết hợp này thì
nó sẽ như nào? Nó sẽ chính là cái nền
tảng của các cái hệ thống gợi ý hay là
các cái recommendation system. cái
recommend system t như này các bạn tưởng
tượng nhá giống như kiểu mà các bạn đi
mua đồ ở trên Amazon hoặc là eBay ấ đúng
không? Amazon hoặc là eBay á thì bây giờ
khi mà các bạn mua một cái món đồ mà tức
là các bạn chưa mua đâu. Các bạn chỉ cần
các bạn chọn hoặc là các bạn tương tác
hoặc là các bạn làm cái gì đấy với một
cái item gì đấy thì lập tức là hệ thống
ấy nó sẽ gợi ý cho bạn những cái sản
phẩm mà có thể các bạn cũng sẽ quan tâm
đúng không? Thì đây chính là cách thức
vận hành của các cái của cái bài toán
association và nó là nền tảng của các
cái recommendation system. Đấy hoặc là
các bạn xem một cái phim trên Netflix
các bạn nhiều khi các bạn không xem hết
phim đâu. Các bạn chỉ cần các bạn tìm
kiếm bộ phim thôi là lập tức là nó sẽ
gửi ý cho bạn một cái list những cái
phim mà có thể các bạn quan tâm. Thì đấy
cũng chính là ví dụ của bài toán
association. Thì những cái hệ thống gợi
ý nó là một cái thành phần rất là quan
trọng cho những công ty là về bảng B2C.
B2C là business to customer, tức là họ
bán sản phẩm trực tiếp cho khách hàng.
Đấy.
[hắng giọng]
Vậy thì classing tự tìm điểm khác và
phân chia thành các nhóm. Nhiệm vụ của
bài toán classing là gì? Là phân chia dữ
liệu vào k cụm khác nhau sao cho các cái
dữ liệu trong cụm một cụm nó sẽ tương
đồng nhau và các cái điểm dữ liệu trong
cụm này và cụm kia nó khác biệt nhau.
Đấy là mục đích của bài toán clustering
nhá. Sau classing nó có đưa ra lý do
phân loại không? Làm sao nó có thể đưa
ra lý do được? Bằng cách nào nó có thể
đưa ra lý do được? Đứa trẻ 3 tuổi các
bạn không có nó không có chỉ dẫn cho nó
thì làm sao nó giải thích được? Đó.
>> Ok.
>> Dạ anh ơi.
>> Ừ.
>> À hôm em có hiểu đúng không nha?
>> [hắng giọng]
>> À em ví dụ như là kiểu như là mình công
ty mình có nhiều khách hàng
>> ừ
>> xong rồi mỗi khách hàng thì sẽ có một
cái hành vi mua sắm khác nhau.
>> Ừ
>> thì mình có thể giả sử là mình sẽ phân
cụng khách hàng dựa trên cái số tiền chi
tiêu của khách hàng cho sản phẩm của
công ty mình. À thì cái thuật toán
clustering này sẽ tính toán độ tương
đồng giữa những cái khách hàng với nhau
và những khách hàng nào mà có cái độ
tương đồng cao về cái về cái hành vi mua
hàng thì nó sẽ gom chung một nhóm
nhá. đấy là cái ý muốn của chúng ta đúng
không? Đấy là ý muốn của chúng ta. Nếu
may mắn có thể cái mô hình này nó sẽ
phân cụ khách hàng ra thành hai nhóm.
Nhóm VIP và và nhóm thường đúng không?
Nhưng cũng có thể nó sẽ phân cụm thành
hai nhóm. Khách nam ra một nhóm, khách
nữ sang một nhóm hoặc khách già sang một
nhóm, khách trẻ sang một nhóm đúng
không? Đấy là bài toán classing đúng
không? Có thể các bạn kỳ vọng nó sẽ phân
cụm theo cái ý này nhưng tại vì nó là dữ
liệu không được đình nhãn nên nó phân
cụm theo cái theo cái direction nào thì
chúng ta sẽ không kiểm soát được đúng
không? Đấy. Đấy là bài toán clastering
đấy.
Các bạn nên nhớ là gì? Cái dữ liệu các
bạn đưa vào mô hình là dữ liệu không
được đánh nhãn nên chúng ta đừng mong là
mô hình nó sẽ tự luận ra nhãn. Điều đấy
là không có nhá. Ok. Anh có câu hỏi gì
nữa không?
Có. Magic đển kế thting tức là nó có một
cái matric để nó đánh giá xem là cái mức
độ tương đồng giữa các cái điểm trong
cùng một cluster và cái sự khác biệt
giữa điểm của cluster này với cluster
kia. Thế nhưng mà cái magic của bài toán
clustering ấ nhìn chung là nó rất là khó
để có thể có thể sử dụng trong thực tế.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì đơn giản chúng ta
không có nhãn đúng không? Có thể hai
sample nó tương đồng nhau nhưng ý nghĩa
nó lại khác nhau là chuyện hoàn toàn
bình thường. Thế là chúng ta không có
nhãn nên là chúng ta tính được magic thì
có tính nhưng mà rất là khó để có thể
dùng nó trong thực tế.
Nó sẽ phân cục dướ một cái đặc trưng gì
đó mà chúng ta không kiểm soát được.
Chúng ta không biết đặc trưng mà cái mô
hình nó dựa vào là cái gì. Chúng ta chỉ
biết là mô hình nó sẽ phân cụm theo cái
cách hiểu của nó. cách nó nhìn nhận dữ
liệu làm sao để cho các dữ liệu nó vào
các cái cụm khác nhau. Có thế thôi. Còn
nhãn các bạn đừng mong giải thích được
cái ý nghĩa tại vì nó là unsovai. Ăn
super vai các bạn sẽ không giải thích
được ý nghĩa của từng cụm.
Có chứ. Ví dụ như này. Ví dụ như này.
Bây giờ trong một công ty mình có ba ông
HR đúng không? Mình có ba ông mình có ba
ông recruitor. Bây giờ mình muốn phân
chia các cái application ra cho ba ông
này thì bây giờ mình sẽ dùng cing
clustering. Mình sẽ mình dùng th toán
clustering để mình phân chia nó làm ba
cụm. Sau đó mình đưa cho ba ông này.
Đấy, đấy là ứng dụng của bài toán
question đúng không? Thay vì mình phân
chia cách random thì mình sẽ phân chia
ba cụm. Mình sẽ biết là ba cụm này mỗi
một cụm nó sẽ nó sẽ tương đồng nhau về
một về một cái mặt nào đấy. Nhưng chúng
ta không biết cụ thể là mặt gì. Chúng ta
chỉ muốn là gì? Là cái ông HR nào mà phụ
trách cái đống application nào ấ thì cái
application nó sẽ na ná nó sẽ tư đồng
nhau. Còn cụ thể là na ná tự đồng về cái
gì chúng ta không có kiểm soát. Thế thôi
nhá. Nhớ cái sự khác biệt giữa
classification classification và
clasuring nhá. Với những người mới học
rất hay bị nhầm giữa hai cái này. Với
người mới học rất hay bị nhầm giữa hai
cái này nhá. Classification là học có
đám sát còn classing là học không có đám
sát nhá.
Bạn nào câu hỏi gì nữa không? Đấy nhá.
Thế còn cái association ấy nó chính là
cái ví dụ của những cái hệ thống gợi ý
mà các bạn dùng trên các cái sàn thương
mại điện tử các sàn Amazon, eBay, Shopee
đấy. Đấy chính là nó đấy.
Rồi đấy là hai mảng Sii và Ansovi. Thông
thường khi các bạn học trong cái trường
đại học cao đẳng thì các bạn phần lớn
thời gian để các bạn có thể tìm hiểu về
hai cái mảng này. Covide là nhiều thời
gian nhất. Ăn si sẽ ít thời gian hơn và
cái ứng dụng nó cũng hạn chế hơn. Hạn
chế tại vì là cái output đồ ra chúng ta
chúng ta khó giải thích đúng không? Cái
output đầu ra của cái nó rất là khó có
thể giải thích được. Đấy.
Tuy nhiên nó có ứng dụng đấy các bạn
thấy cái hệ thống gợi ý nó chính là ứng
dụng đấy. Association chính là một cái
bài toán, một trong hai bài toán chính
của uns learning. [khịt mũi] Thế còn cái
mảng thứ ba? Cái mảng thứ ba là cái mảng
mà gần như các bạn sẽ không bao giờ có
thể tìm được chop ở Việt Nam. Cái mảng
thứ ba là mảng reinforcementing. Các bạn
rất khó có thể tìm được chop ở cái mảng
này. Cái mảng này nó vừa khó học, chop
nó vừa ít
và nó lại còn ờ nó không cạnh tranh. Tại
vì đơn giản là gần như nó cũng chả có
quay học cái mảng này cả. Gần như chả có
học cái mảng reinforce này cả. Như nhưng
mà cái bản này nó rất là thú vị. Cái bản
nó rất là thú vị. qua là nó khó ừ nó khó
áp dụng khó ứng ứng dụng thôi. Thì cái
ví dụ là trong supervine phải supervide
á
có hướng nghiên cứu nhưng mà các bạn sẽ
rất là chí các bạn vào những công ty như
kiểu là Vin ấy thì may ra nó có cái
phòng nghiên cứu về cái reforce link còn
không các bạn hóa các bạn rất là khó và
muốn học được cái bài này các bạn phải
rất là giỏi toán rất là chắc toán còn
nếu các bạn toán mà ngày xưa nếu các bạn
học phổ thông ấy nếu các bạn học phổ
thông toán nó không phải là môn chủ lực
của các bạn nếu toán nó không phải là
cái môn mà các bạn học tốt nhất thì
thông thường các bạn không nên theo cái
bản này nhá thông thường các bạn sẽ
không nên theo cái bả nếu ngày xưa toán
là cái môn mà các bạn nhìn thấy đề bài
thi mà các bạn không bị tăng nhịp tim ấy
thì các bạn học được. Còn nếu ngày xưa
các bạn nhìn thấy mà các bạn team đập
chân run ấy thì các bạn không nên học
cái mảng reforce learning này nó rất là
khó mà job thì gần như là không có. Kể
cả ở thị trường châu Âu job về cái mảng
này rất là ít luôn, rất là ít. Nếu có
cái job mảng này thường nó sẽ vào trong
môi trường nghiên cứu. Đấy. Thế thì cái
nếu mà trong super về á cái đối tượng mà
các bạn cần huấn luyện người ta gọi là
model là mô hình đúng không? Chúng ta
huấn luyện cái model. Thế thì trong
reinforcement learning ấy cái đối tượng
mà chúng ta cần phải huấn luyện ấy người
ta sẽ không gọi nó là model mà người ta
gọi nó là agent hay là tác nhân. Được
chưa? Hay là tác nhân. Thế thì cái ý
tưởng của reinforcement là gì? Đó là
chúng ta sẽ đặt cái tác nhân này trong
một cái môi trường, trong một cái
environment gì đấy. Đúng không? Trong
environment gì đấy. Thế thì trong cái
môi trường này ấy, cái tác nhân ấy nó sẽ
tương tác với môi trường xung quanh nhá.
Trong môi trường này thì cái tác nhân nó
sẽ liên tục nó sẽ tương tác với môi
trường xung quanh. Và ở trong cái sau
khi mà khi mà nó tương tác như vậy ấy
thì khi mà nó tương tác như vậy thì cứ
mỗi một lần mà cái tác nhân nó tương tác
tương tác là gì t nó thể hiện những cái
hành vi nhá. Tương tác ở đây tức là tôi
một cái action gì đấy và cứ mỗi một cái
action mà cái con tác nhân ấy nó thực
hiện ấy thì môi trường sẽ gửi lại cho nó
một cái phản hồi, một cái feedback. Cái
phản hồi này trong reinforcement
learning người ta gọi nó là reward.
Reward là phần thưởng. Nếu mà cái hành
động mà cái tác nhân này nó làm nó tốt
ấy thì cái reward này nó sẽ là positive
reward. Thế còn nếu hành đệ bộ này nó
tồi ấy thì đây sẽ một cái negative
reward hay người ta gọi là penalty đúng
không? Penalty trong bóng trong bóng đá
ấy mình phạt đấy đúng không? Đấy. Thế
thì cái con tác nhân ấy nó sẽ liên tục
nó tương tác với môi trường thông qua
việc nó thiện những cái hành động như
vậy và nó sẽ liên tục nó nhận về những
cái feedback và cứ dần dần nó sẽ càng
ngày nó sẽ càng optimize. Làm sao nó sẽ
hành động làm sao để nó có thể optimize
cái phần thưởng nó nhận về đúng không?
Nó optimize cái rew mà nó nhận về. Thì
đấy chính là cái ý tưởng của
reinforcement learning. Mình lấy cho bạn
một cái ví dụ nhá. Bây giờ ví dụ các bạn
tưởng tượng là cái tác nhân ấy nó là một
cái đứa trẻ. Được chưa? Tác nhân nó là
một cái đứa trẻ. Các bạn đặt nó trong
một cái căn phòng có một cái đốm lửa ở
chính giữa. Được chưa? Thì căn phòng và
đốm lửa nó chính là cái environment. Các
bạn đặt tác nhân vào trong môi trường
thì bây giờ tác nhân nó sẽ bắt đầu nó
tương tác với môi trường. Nó tương tác
bằng cái nào? Nó tương tác bằng cái nó
hiện cái hành động đúng không? Hành động
của đứa trẻ là gì? Là nó bò đúng không?
Hành động của trẻ là nó bò. Thế bây giờ
ấy nếu một cái đứa trẻ nó bò gần cái đốm
nó bò gần vào cái đốm đ đốm lửa ấy thì
cái môi trường tức là cái căn phòng với
cái đốm lửa nó sẽ trả về cho đứa trẻ một
cái feedback là gì? Là cái cảm giác ấm
đúng không? Cái cảm giác ấm lên. Cái cảm
giác ấm lên này nó là một cái positive
reward thì đứa trẻ nó sẽ biết là gì? À
tôi bò gần vào đốm lửa thì tôi sẽ được
ấm. Đúng không? Đó chính là positive
reward.
Thế nhưng nếu mà đứa trẻ nó bò vào gần
cái đốm lửa quá ấy thì nó sẽ nhận về một
cái negative reward. Tức là nó bị nóng
quá đúng không? Thì cái sự nóng quá này
nó chính là cái negative nó nhận phải
negative reward mà cái đ mà cái đứa đứa
trẻ nó nhận phải đúng không? Thế t có
nghĩa là gì? Có nghĩa là cái hành động
mà cái tác nhân nó làm nó tốt ấy nó sẽ
nhận được cái reward dương còn hành động
nó thể hiện nó tồi ấy nó sẽ hiện cái
reward âm và nó cứ lắp đi lại những cái
hành động khác nhau như vậy để làm sao
nó tối ưu được cái hành động của nó. Tối
ưu hành động có nghĩa là gì? Tức là tôi
làm những hành động để làm sao tôi sẽ
tối ưu hóa được cái reward mà tôi nhận
về. Đấy chính là cái qu đấy chính là cái
quá trình phát triển của cái quá trình
chúng ta huấn luyện với reinforcement
learning. Và nhớ là gì? Trong
reinforcementing người ta không gọi là
model, người ta gọi là agent là tác
nhân. Cái mảng này nó nặc về toán hơn
rất nhiều so với hai cái mảng kia. Ờ nó
có rất nhiều ứng dụng rất là hay, rất là
thú vị. Thế nhưng mà mỗi tội là cái mảng
này thì nó khó và cơ hội vượt làm nó rất
là ít. Mình cho các bạn xem thử cái ứng
dụng của reinforcement learning nhá. Các
bạn nhìn này. Ứng dụng của
reinforcementing lại như này
anh nhá.
Đây là những cái project cá nhân mình
xây dựng hồi mình mới ra trường mình có
nhiều thời gian mình mới ra trường mình
làm một vài những cái project cá nhân
như này
l mình có nào dùng gitub không lớp mình
có ai dùng gitub không gitub nó coi là
một cái bảng CV của các lập trình viên
ấy
đây là ghub của mình
đây chỗ mình cho các bạn xem thế nào là
reinforce learning nhá à trước khi nói
về reinforce learning các bạn nhìn này
hầu hết nhá hầu hết mọi người hầu hết
mọi người biết đến Open AI thông qua
chat GBT đúng không? Thế nhưng mà thật
ra ấy Open AI nó một công ty nó nổi
trong AI rất là lâu rồi. Từ những ngày
từ từ 2015 các thứ họ đã rất là nổi
tiếng rồi. Ví dụ này với mình thì mình
biết đến Open lần đầu tiên vào năm 2018.
Năm 2018 thì Open AI họ cho ra mắt một
cái một cái a sản phẩm gọi là Open AI.
Open5
nó không phải là nó không phải là GPD5
đâu. Nó là Open5. Đây nó như thế này năm
2018. Open I5 nó là cái gì? Nó là năm
con boss, năm cái mạng Neuron có khả
năng chơi game Dota 2 cùng với nhau.
Ngày trước ấy trước 2018 ấy thì đã có
rất nhiều cái mô hình AI có thể đánh bại
con người ở các cái tựa game khác nhau
rồi. Nhưng mà cái điểm chung của các tự
game này là gì? Là đều là các cái tựa
game solo đúng không? Đều các cái tự
game solo. Solo có nghĩa là gì? Solo có
nghĩa là các bạn chiến chơi giỏi là các
bạn thắng đúng không? Các bạn chuyển
giỏi, các bạn giỏi hơn đối thủ là các
bạn có thể đánh bại đối phương rồi. Thế
nhưng mà ở các cái tự game đồng đội thì
một câu chuyện khác. Ở tự game đồng đội
các bạn có chơi giỏi mà đồng đội các bạn
nó tạ thì các bạn cũng không thể thắng
được đúng không? Bạn nào các bạn chơi
game kiểu liên minh huyền thoại hoặc là
Dota hoặc là Counterstrike rồi các bạn
biết cái cảm giác đấy đúng không? Nhiều
khi các bạn chơi giỏ ấy nhưng mà đồng
đội các bạn ngu thì các bạn vẫn thua
đúng không? Thế thì với cây tự đồng đội
ấy mình chơi giỏi là không đủ mà mình
phải phối hợp được với đồng đội nữa đúng
không? Thế và vào năm 2018 thì lần đầu
tiên chúng ta đã chứng kiến là một cái
con boss AI nó có thể đánh thắng con
người ở một game đồng đội. Cái team của
con người này không phải team vớ vẩn
đâu. Cái team con người này toàn là các
cựu pro player rồi toàn các cái streamer
đấy. Toàn các cựu pro player, toàn các
cái cựu streamer về Dota 2. Tức là họ là
những người chơi mà kỹ năng rất là tốt
rồi đúng không? Họ chơi Dota hàng ngày
rồi. Họ và thuộc vào cái top 0,005 những
người chơi
những người chơi Dota giả nhất thế giới.
Thế nhưng mà họ bị thua trước cái team
này. Team gồm năm con boss. Thế thì nói
qua một chút là à người ta phải huấn
luyện năm con boss này. Ờ tất nhiên là
với Reforce Leing rồi và họ phải cái
nguồn dữ liệu gì? Là các cái game mà
chúng ta các cái game mà con người đã
từng chơi Dota trước đây. Tổng thời gian
các cái game này nó nó vào khoảng là 180
năm. Tức là nếu các bạn ghép các cái
video các cái game này vào lại nó sẽ
tương ưng với 180 năm. Đấy thì nhưng mà
khi mà tôi huấn luyện cái mùi này chỉ
cần vài vài ngày thôi. Vài ngày thôi đấy
huấn luyện cái môn này nó chỉ vài ngày
thôi là cái lượng dữ liệu cho huấn luyện
là tương đương với 185. Đấy hình như là
cho mỗi một con mỗi một con là 185 thì
về. Thế đây là cái cấu hình các thứ này
đấy đúng không? Thế và kết quả là gì? Là
open năm con boss này đã chỉ thắng đội
team con người. Tất nhiên nó có một vài
những cái giới hạn là gì? là mỗi bên chỉ
chọn một trong 18 con tướng thôi chứ
không được chọn tất cả các con tướng.
Thế nhưng mà dù như vậy thì dù sao đây
cũng là một cái cột mốc rất là đáng nhớ
trong lịch sử phát triển của AI khi mà
lần đầu tiên AI có thể đánh mạnh con
người ở một tựa game đồng đội.
Đây chính là một cái sản phẩm của
Reforce Learning. OB họ họ nổi tiếng rất
là lâu rồi. Chẳng qua là đến lúc mà
chúng ta có chat GPT thì nó tiếp cận gần
tới người dùng phổ thông thôi. Chứ còn
trong giới AI ấy thì công ty này một
công ty nổi đình nổi đã từ rất là lâu
rồi. Công ty này với một công ty nữa một
cái startup có trụ sở ở London và bây
giờ bị mua lại bởi Google rồi đó là
Google Deppy.
Đây là hai công ty có rất nhiều ngày xưa
là công ty lúc ban đầu nó họ họ họ là
startup chở London sau khi họ bị mua lại
bởi Google thì bây giờ ta gọi là Google
DIP. Đế thì đây là hai công ty có rất là
nhiều những cái đóng góp cho cái sự phát
triển của reinforcement learning. Đấy và
thậm chí là bây giờ khi mà người ta cái
phiên bản GPT4 ấ người ta GPT3 GPT4
người ta cải thiện ờ người ta cải thiện
cái chất lượng của con GPT thông qua một
cái thuật toán là reinforcementing form
human feedback này đây là cái đây là cái
thuật toán mà người ta dùng để người ta
có thể cải thiện con GPT
3 hay 4 thì mình cũng không nhớ rõ lắm
đấy reinforce learning đây này đấy
reinforce learning đấy học tăng cường
cho các bạn xem ví dụ nhá đây là cái
phiên bản đơn giản hơn này mình thì tất
nhiên cái đây là cái thuật toán Toán PPO
cái toán nền tảng đứng đằng sau Open A5
thì tất nhiên là cái phiên bản mình nó
đơn giản hơn mình chỉ chơi game đơn giản
thôi. Bạn nào mà cái lứa cuối 8x đầu 9x
như mình chắc là các bạn không còn xa lạ
gì với game này đúng không? Lớp mình có
ai đã từng chơi game này bao giờ chưa?
Đấy ngày xưa cái game này là tuổi thơ
của mình đấy. Ngày xưa mà không không
chưa có chưa có cái máy chưa có internet
các thứ ấy là là chơi game này này đúng
không các bạn lứa bây giờ chắc các bạn
chả các bạn chơi mấy game kiểu này cả
đúng không? Nhưng mà thời ngày xưa thì
mình chơi rất là nhiều. Mình rất là
thích cái game này. Cái game này nó kiểu
này, tức là nó có 32 màn. Nó chia làm
mình cũng chả biết tải thế nào cho các
bạn. Tức là nó có 32 màn. Tóm lại là như
vậy. Thế nhưng mà thường người chơi
người ta sẽ chả qua người ta chơi hết 32
màn đâu mà nó sẽ nó sẽ có có những cái
cổng shortcut, có những cái cổng đi tắt
ấy. Đấy cái game này ngày xưa mình chơi
thì mình chơi mình chơi rất là kém. Mình
không mình không chơi được nhiều. Mình
tức là không phải tức là mình chơi rất
là nhiều nhưng mà mình chẳng phá đảo bao
giờ cả.
Mình rất là thích chơi nhưng mình không
mình chơi không có giỏi. Thế nên là mình
cái con AI mà mình dùng reinforceing
dùng cái thật toán PPO này để mình có
thể hướng dẫn nó chơi cái game cái game
này nhưng mà nó cũng chỉ gây chữ được 31
game thôi. Đúng game cuối nó không phá
đảo được. Bạn nào các bạn chơi các bạn
từng chơi cái game cuối này các bạn sẽ
biết là cái game cuối nó có một cái điểm
là nó có những cái ô mà nó có những cái
ô mà các bạn phải đập nó trong cái không
gian mà không có cái gì cả. Đúng không?
Đây con người chúng ta biết cái đấy
nhưng mà máy nó không nó không luận ra
cái đấy được. Đấy thì cái này nó có 32 m
thì con của mình nó hoàn thành được 31.
Thì đây là một cái ví dụ của reinforce
learning. Các bạn thấy trong này tức là
gì? Cái con Mario ấy nó sẽ là Asian đúng
không? Cái môi trường xung quanh nó
chính là environment. Thế bây giờ những
cái con Mario này mình định nghĩa nó như
nào? Tức là bây giờ nếu mà nó cứ di
chuyển được sang phải nó sẽ được cái
positive reward. Được chưa? Nó mà giết
được quái nó cộng thêm điểm nó ăn được
nấm thì nó sẽ được positive reward. Nó
bị chết là nhận negative. Nó mà chạm vào
cái cờ của sân ấy nó sẽ nhận cái
positive rất là lớn đúng không? Thì đấy
là cái ý tưởng của mình. Thế ngoài ra
thì còn có một vài những game khác ví dụ
như là gì? Thì ví dụ như là đây ví dụ
như là Flappy Bird này bên này chắc chắn
các bạn chơi rồi đúng không? Flappy Bird
chắc chắn các bạn phải chơi rồi đúng
không? Đây đây là một cái ví dụ của
Reforce Learning mình trên con này trong
phòng 2 triệu iteration 2 triệu bước lặp
thì nó được như này.
Con này định nghĩa con này định nghĩa
còn dễ hơn. Con này định nghĩa như nào?
Tứ mỗi một khung hình nó còn sống thì nó
được cộng 0,1 điểm. Nếu nó đi qua được
hai cái ô này, hai cái ống cống ấy nó
được cộng thêm một điểm. Nếu nó chết nó
bị trừ một điểm. Thế thôi, rất là đơn
giản như thế này. Hoặc là với game xếp
hình, game xếp hình đây.
Dình là như này.
Đây các em sẽ hình như này.
Được chưa? Các em sẽ hình như này.
Thế
ừ nhưng mà của mình là phiên bản đơn
giản hơn. Tại vì của mình là không cần
phải phối hợp cái gì cả. Cái con thế còn
con open kia là năm con nó phải phù hợp
với nhau nó còn phức tạp hơn nhiều nhưng
của mình là là một mình mình chơi thôi
của mình là phiên bản đơn giản thôi phi
của mình nó đơn giản hơn rất là nhiều so
với phiên bản gốc
thế thì đây là về reinforce learning thế
ngoài ra reinforceing nó có thể nó có
một cái mảng ứng dụng rất là hay của
reinforce learing đó là về trong
autonomous driving trong lái tự động ấy
trong autonomous driving ấy thì cái ý
tưởng là gì là bây giờ ấy tôi phải làm
sao tôi huấn luyện được một cái xe ô tô
nó tự lái được mà không cần phải có
người ngồi lái đúng không? Thế thì cái
xe ô tô nó chính là agent. Thế nhưng mà
tất nhiên là lúc mới ban đầu ấy thì chả
ai người ta dám cho con agent này nó chả
ai dám cho con agent này vào trong môi
trường thực tế cả đúng không? Người ta
sẽ thể sử dụng cái môi trường mô phỏng.
Thì trong cái môi trường mô phỏng này
thì người ta sẽ mô phỏng những cái xe cộ
các thứ rồi đường xá rồi người hết các
thứ đúng không? Thì cái môi trường mô
phòng này nó chính là environment. Cái
xe của mình nó chính là Asian. Thế thì
trong cái môi trường mô phòng này cái xe
mình nó hiện nãy tương tác với môi
trường thông qua việc nó thực hiện những
cái action những cái hành động đúng
không? Một cái xe có những hành động gì?
Đi tiến, đi lùi, rẽ trái, rẽ phải,
phanh, xi nhan, bóp còi, thăng tốc, giảm
tốc, đúng không? Đấy là những cái hành
động cái xe nó có thể làm. Thế thì bây
giờ nếu mà cái xe nó làm những cái hành
động mà có cái kết quả tốt ấy, ví dụ là
gì? Nó đi đúng làn đường, nó tuân thủ
biển báo, nó không đông vào ai cả, nó có
xi nhan đầy đủ các thứ đúng không? Thì
nó sẽ nhận một cái positive reward. Thế
còn ở chị hướng ngược lại nóế nếu mà nó
làm gì nữa mà nó đâm vào ông này đâm vào
ông kia, nó lao lên vỉa hè, nó đi trái
làn đường, nó đi vật đèn đỏ chẳng hạn
thì nó về cái negative reward. Thì trong
cái môi trường phảỏ này nó cứ tương tác
với cái môi trường liên tục như vậy nó
sẽ nhận về những cái feedback liên tục.
Và sau đó thì khi mà cái xe này nó đã đủ
tốt rồi ấy thì người ta sẽ đưa nó ra
trong môi trường thật. Nhưng mà trong
môi trường thật này người ta cũng sẽ
chưa cho nó ra ngoài đường ngay đâu.
Người ta sẽ phải cho một cái môi trường
giới hạn. Môi trường giới hạn là gì? Tức
là có đường phố nhưng mà không có người
thật đúng không? Có thể có xe cộ các thứ
thì chúng ta phải chuyên tiếp nó trong
cái môi trường này. Khi mà nó đủ tốt rồi
chúng ta sẽ đem nó ra ngoài trong thực
tế.
các cái công tư các cái công ty như kiểu
là Tesla, Uber hay là BMW ấ họ đều có
những cái phòng nghiên cứu về automate
driving. Đấy
cái ứng dụng của Refor nó rất là hay
nhưng mà mỗi tội đó nó rất là khó. Cái
bài này nó học nó rất là khó thuật toán
các thứ nó nặng hơn rất là nhiều so với
hai cái mảng kia. Và cái về cái về cái
phạm vi ứng dụng nó cũng nhìn chung nó
cũng hơi bị hẹp hơn so với hai cái mảng
kia. Thế nên là thông thường các cái
chương trình học về AI ấy cái mảng
reinforce ly nếu các bạn có học nó các
bạn chỉ học rất là thoáng qua thôi và
thậm chí là có nhiều người ta còn chả
học cái mảng này luôn. Các bạn hoàn toàn
các bạn có thể có thể đi làm kỹ sư AI mà
các bạn không biết gì về cái mảng này
tại vì đây là một cái mảng rất là hiếm.
Mảng nó rất là hiếm.
Ngày xưa mình mới ra trường mình thấy
cái reinforcement learning khó giống như
Việt nói nhưng mà mình thấy nó lại rất
là hay và nhiều thực tế trong cuộc sống.
>> Ví dụ cái ví dụ Việt vừa giờ show cho
bọn mình là về game chẳng hạn ở game
đồng nội và môi trường tương tác môi
trường và cái Tesla chẳng hạn. Nhưng mà
ví dụ cho mình thoáng nghĩ ra những cái
ví dụ như trong tương lai có một cái con
robot chẳng hạn, một robot giúp việc
chẳng hạn nó sẽ tương tác với cả đấy mới
dụ chính xác
>> người bệnh chẳng hạn hoặc là giúp việc
trong nhà thì cái đấy cái ứng dụng đấy
nó thực ra theo ý hiểu mình nó ở một
đẳng cấp rất là cao hơn và
>> và và rất là hay thú vị. Nhưng Việt Nam
mình không có. Nhưng như thế thì ví dụ ở
các thị trường nước ngoài ví dụ Châu Âu,
Đức Pháp thì bây giờ nó họ vẫn còn ứng
dụng trong quá trình tặng t AI đúng
không? Ví dụ ví dụ là ví dụ như em ở Đức
chẳng hạn thì ví dụ lên những trang
trang cái tìm tìm kiếm việc ấy thì cái
job về cái mảng này gần như là tuyệt
chủng rất hiếm
>> nước ở Đức cũng tuyệt chủng á.
>> Vâng. Tại vì là tại vì là thường là
thường là các cái phòng nghiên cứu họ sẽ
nghiên cứu cái này mà trong phòng nghiên
cứu thì họ đã có sẵn PhD student rồi. Họ
đã có sẵn nghiên cứu rồi. Còn các công
ty thì thường nó sẽ công ty nó sẽ ứng
dụng những thứ có sẵn những cái thứ mà
đã được chứng minh các thứ rồi để người
ta áp dụng vào. Công ty thì sẽ không làm
cái này. Thường chỉ có những phòng
nghiên cứu thì họ mới làm. Mà phòng
nghiên cứu thì đội ngũ họ đã là hùng hậu
rồi và họ không bao giờ họ phải tuyển
thêm người ngoài cả. Đấy. Tại vì khi mà
ở phòng nghiên cứu người ta đều là bảo
là những người học rất là giỏi rồi. Lên
PSD đều phải người học rất là giỏi, phải
có cái đức toán nhất định. Rồi cái bản
này nó đặc biệt nặng về toán. Ờ tất
nhiên
>> nhưng mà những sinh viên giỏi về toán mà
ví dụ tiếp nối những những chuyên gia
đầu ngành về sau họ vẫn sẽ phải có những
thế hệ kế cận thì những cái sinh viên và
giỏi toán về hướng này thì họ vẫn có thể
theo được và hướng về cái mảng này đúng
không? về vào các cái phòng nghiên cứu.
>> Đúng rồi. Thế nhưng mà thế nhưng mà cái
mảng này thường là sẽ phải học lên cao.
Tức là ví dụ cái mức PSD người ta sẽ
nghiên cứu nhiều. Thế còn cái mức master
về bao thì thường là nó sẽ rất là ít.
Tại vì bacho với master thường những
người người ta ngắm ra cái hướng ứng
dụng và cái hướng đi ra ngoài làm. Đi ra
ngoài làm công ty mà học cái bản này thì
gần như là không thể xin việc được. Tại
vì đơn giản là không có việc.
Nhưng mà còn một ngoài ngoài cái cái ví
dụ robot hơi cao nhưng mà bây giờ bây
giờ nó phát triển rất nhiều cái về cái
AI agent về cái cái
>> a a a à cái AI agent mà mọi người hay
nghe ấy nó không phải cái agent này. Đây
là hai cái agent phải tại vì cái đấy nó
cũng tương tác với môi trường ví dụ như
cái thằng CL code chẳng hạn nó cũng cho
vào cái môi trường doanh nghiệp lập
trình và các cái ruler và tất cả những
convention của môi trường nó cũng phản
ứng với cả những môi trường
>> không? Tức là em nói cái là cái mà mọi
người hay nói về Asian trong kiểu L ấ
Asient với kiểu Aentic AI ấy. Cái Asient
đấy với agent này nó hai cái nó khác
nhau.
>> Cái
>> nó khác nhau. Hai cái nó khác nhau. Cái
agent mọi người hay nói vì LM nó khác
hoàn toàn thế này. Nó chỉ dùng cùng cái
chữ agent thôi nhưng mà ý nghĩa nó khác
nhau
>> không? Nhưng mà nhưng mà ý ý mình hiểu
nó cũng là một tác nhân nó cũng là ném
nó vào một cái môi trường mà đúng nó
mình cũng không ném nó vào môi trường.
Chỉ đơn giản trong trong các cái môi
ngôn ngữ lớn thì nó sẽ nói là kiểu khác.
Nó sẽ huấn luyện. Đầu tiên là người ta
sẽ tiền huấn luyện nó với một cái bộ
rượu rất là lớn và không có nhãn để làm
thành một cái người ta gọi là foundation
model là một cái mô hình nền tảng. Tức
người ta sẽ huện nó để làm sao? Để đầu
tiên là huấn luyện nó để nó hiểu ngôn
ngữ đã. Sau khi nó hiểu ngôn ngữ rồi tôi
sẽ bắt đầu tôi sẽ ờ tôi tôi sẽ huấn
luyện nói với một cái bộ dữ liệu có đánh
nhãn để phụ một cái bài toán gì đây. Thế
thế còn với đấy là về đấy là mô hình
ngôn ngữ lớn. Thế còn về agent là gì? Nó
sẽ có thêm cái đoạn là gì? nó sẽ có khả
năng nó có thể dùng công cụ ví dụ là nó
có thể nó có khả năng nó gửi mail, nó
tra cứu nhiệt độ ngoài trời, nó ờ viết
email chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy đấy, đấy
là cái ý nghĩa của agent đấy. Nó nó
không phải agent này, nó không phải
agent này. Đấy, cái agent đấy nó không
tương tác gì nó tức là nó cái agent đấy
nó tương tác nhưng mà nó không nó không
nhận feedback từ môi trường về. Nó viết
email xong, nó search thông tin về nhận
ngoài trời xong, nó không nhận phản hồi
gì từ môi trường về cả. Thì đấy không
phải là reinforcement learning. nó không
à mình nhầm mình ví dụ như ở trong cái
cái viber code ví dụ clot code chẳng hạn
nó nó tương tác với người dùng thì nó
cũng không nhận không nhận tại vì à tức
là mình sẽ liên tục đặt câu hỏi cho nó
chẳng hạn mình hỏi nó làm gì làm này ờ
cái đấy thì có thể quá trình người ta
huấn luyện nó có thể có reinforce
learning nhưng mà cái feedback mà chúng
ta phản hồi về ấy thì đấy không phải
reinforce learning cái đấy chỉ là các
bạn hỏi lại nó mọi người hỏi nó rồi nó
nó trả lời lại cho nó đến chúng ta hài
lòng thì thôi chứ cái đấy nó không phải
reinforce learning reinforce learning nó
nó sẽ không kiểu là real time Thế tức là
tôi sẽ buộc vào ngay mà tôi sẽ phải làm
từ trước khi mà tôi triển khai nó rồi.
>> Dạ. Dạ. Ok.
>> Dạ.
>> Ok.
>> Thấy nhá. Nhìn chung với các bạn như
mình nói rồi, các bạn hoàn toàn chẳng
biết một tí gì về reinforce learning.
Các bạn vẫn hoàn toàn an toàn. You are
safe. Các bạn không phải lo về cái bảng
ấy. Mình chỉ giới điệu để các bạn biết
là gì? À trong machining có cái mảng
này. Thế thôi. Thế nhưng mà như mình nói
trừ khi là các bạn không có gánh nặng về
cơm áo gạo tiền. Các bạn không có cái
gánh nặng vì việc là các bạn phải đi xin
việc thì các bạn có thể dành thời gian
các bạn nghiên cứu cái bảng này. Còn
không thì lời khuyên của mình rất là
chân thành cho các bạn là gì? Là đừng để
ý quá nhiều cái bảng này mà nó nó rất là
hay. Thế nhưng mà như mình nói rồi các
bạn sẽ rất là khó các bạn phải tìm việc
ở Việt Nam về cái mảng này nhá. Được
chưa? Rồi. Supervise unsupervice với cả
reinforce learning. Có bạn nào có câu
hỏi gì không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Rồi tiếp nhá.
B chúng đến phần tiếp theo này các bạn
nhìn này. Thì bây giờ ấy vừa nãy chúng
ta nói về dữ liệu thì bây gi chúng ta sẽ
nói thêm kỹ thêm một chút này. Bây giờ
các bạn có một cái file dữ liệu dạng
bảng như này đúng không? Ví dụ file
Excel là file đúng không? Thế thì cái dữ
liệu này cái file này ấy được gọi là dữ
liệu có đánh nhãn hay là dữ liệu không
được đánh nhãn thì nó còn phải phụ thuộc
vào xem là các bạn muốn đem cái bộ rượu
này để phục vụ bài toán gì nhá. Nếu các
bạn chỉ có một cái bộ rượu này thôi các
bạn sẽ chưa thể kết luận ngay nó là
unlable hay nó là label đúng không? Nếu
các bạn chỉ có dữ liệu, các bạn chưa thể
biết nó là cái gì. Các bạn phải có cả
bài toán nữa thì lúc đấy các bạn mới
biết nó là cái gì. Được chưa? Ví dụ
ví dụ với bài toán dự đoán giá nhà đúng
không? Nếu các bạn có cái bộ rượu này và
các bạn muốn đem nó đi để huấn luyện một
cái mô hình dự án giá nhà thì đây là
label data. Tại vì sao? Tại vì các bạn
có thông tin về cái tagit, các bạn có
thông tin về cái thứ mà các bạn muốn dự
đoán đúng không? Cụ thể là giá nhà đúng
không? Thì với bài toán dự đoán giá nhà
thì đây là label data.
Thế còn đối với bài toán dự đoán năm xây
nhà thì đây sẽ là unlabel data. Tại vì
các bạn chả có thông tin gì về cái thứ
mà các bạn muốn dự đoán cả. Được chưa?
Thế là cùng cái bộ rượu này. Trong bài
toán A thì nó là dữ liệu có đánh nhãn.
Trong bài toán B thì nó là dữ liệu không
được đánh nhãn. Thế nên ấy gọi là label
hay là unlabel các bạn phải biết hai
thứ. Các bạn phải biết về dữ liệu là một
và các bạn biết cái bài toán là hai. Nếu
chỉ có dữ liệu các bạn sẽ không kết luận
được gì cả. Nếu chỉ có dữ liệu, các bạn
chỉ có thể kết luận đây là một dữ liệu
có cấu trúc. Đây là dữ liệu dạng bảng
chấm hết đúng không? Phải biết bài toán
nữa thì mới biết nó là label hay là
unlabel. Được chưa? Và nếu cùng là l lab
label đi đúng không? Trong bài toán dự
đoán giá nhà thì label là cái cột price.
Trong bài toán dự đoán diện tích nhà thì
cái cột square feit mới là cột price
đúng không? Tức là gì? Cùng là label.
Thế nhưng mà trong bài toán này thì
label nó là cột này. Trong bài toán kia
thì label nó là cột kia. Được chưa?
Rồi. Ok. Đến đây có bắt nào câu hỏi gì
không?
Có b nào có câu hỏi?
Machining engineer ngoài cch ngoài việc
xây dựng huấn luyện luyện và triển khai
thật toán họ còn họ còn họ còn phải họ
còn phải deploy và họ phải triển khai
nữa phải triển khai theo thực tế đúng
không cải thiện mua cải thiện cái
performance của machine nó có thể là
nhiệm vụ của data scientist hoặc là
machine thế nhưng mà machine year sẽ
phải triển khai mua hình như thực tế làm
sao triển khai các bạn phải cân nhắc đến
cái việc gì là làm sao mà cái tài nguyên
tính toán nó là tối thiểu này đúng không
tốc độ nó nhanh các thứ chẳng hạn đúng
không? Sau đó đáp ứng được những cái yêu
cầu liên quan đến tốc độ, liên quan đến
bộ nhớ của khách hàng. Đấy và họ ngoài
ra thì họ sẽ phải liên tục họ phải
maintain, họ phải bảo trì và họ phải
update cái mô hình đấy. Thường thì không
phải mô hình các bạn cứ chỉ khai là xong
mà các bạn chỉ phải liên tục các bạn cải
thiện chúng đúng không? Cải thiện qua
cái vòng đời sản phẩm đúng không? Hoặc
là khi mà khách hàng có những cái yêu
cầu gì mới thì làm sao vào phải tích hợp
cái yêu cầu mới đấy vào trong mô hình.
Đây nhiệm vụ của Mia.
À có một cái điểm nữa mình quên cho các
bạn này. Ngoài ba cái nhánh tiêu chuẩn
là supervive, unsupervice với reinforce
learning thì nó có một cái nhánh nữa,
một cái nhánh giữa semi à giữa giữa
super learning với người ta gọi là semi
super learning hay là học bán giám sát.
Học bán giám sát có nghĩa gì?
Học bán giám sát ấy có nghĩa là cái dữ
liệu dùng để phố liệu mô hình ấy là bao
gồm cả dữ liệu có đánh nhãn và dữ liệu
không được đánh nhãn. Thế nhưng mà thông
thường ấy thông thường thì trong cái
trường hợp học án sát như vậy thường cái
số lượng dữ liệu có đánh nhãn nó sẽ in
hơn rất là nhiều so với dữ liệu không
được đánh nhãn nhá. Thế tức là live giữa
hai cái mảng này các bạn sẽ có là semi
supervised learning. Được chưa?
Tiếp này. Thì bây giờ chúng ta sẽ vẫn
nói tiếp đến
dữ liệu. Thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói về
các cái các cái loại đặc trưng trong dữ
liệu. Đặc trưng là cái gì? Đặc trưng ví
dụ đây bài toán dự án giá nhà thì đặc
trưng nó là diện tích này, số tầng với
cả số phòng đúng không? Tức là ngoại trừ
cái cột mà chúng ta cần phải dự đoán ấy,
những cái cột còn lại nó đều là feature
hay là đặc trưng. Được chưa? Thế thì nói
về các cái loại đặc trưng trong trong
data trong dữ liệu dạng bảng ấy nó sẽ có
rất nhiều loại khác nhau nhưng trong đó
thì có hai loại phổ biến và đủ nhiều
nhất. Một là numerical feature và hai là
categorical feature nhá. numerical
feature và categorical feature.
Numerical feature là những cái đặc trưng
dạng số như này đúng không? Số bao gồm
là có thể là số những cái số rời dà tức
là 0,34 -5 -4 -3 -2 vân vân. Thì đấy là
dạng dạng là số rời già đúng không? Tức
là nó là nó là số nguyên đó. Ví dụ đây
trường hợp này nó là số nguyên chẳng hạn
đúng không? Hoặc trường hợp nữa là gì?
Là cái số liên tục tức là cái giá trị
bất kỳ một cái số gì máy phẩy mấy phẩy m
máy phẩy đấy đúng không? Bên trái là
kiểu số nguyên bên phải là kiểu số thực
đúng không? Bên trái là in bên phải là
float. Được chưa? Các bạn nào có học lập
trình các bạn không còn xa lạ gì với
kiểu rượu này đúng không? In flow.
Thế đây là rượu dạng số. Thế nhưng mà có
một cái điểm các bạn cần phải biết này
là gì? Đó là ấy ờ đó là về mặt tức là
hầu hết nhá 90% nếu mà hình thức của dữ
liệu nó là dạng số ấy thì phải đến 90%
nó là num feature. Tuy nhiên nó cũng có
những ngoại lệ. Nó có những ngoại lệ là
gì? Nó có những
nó có những ngoại lệ làm
có những trường hợp là hình thức thì là
dạng số nhưng nó lại không phải nicer
feature. Ví dụ là gì? Ví dụ như là số
điện thoại. Số điện thoại về mặt hình
thức thì nó là num feature nhưng nó lại
không phải là num feature. Tại vì sao?
Tại vì ý nếu mà là num feature nó phải
có ý nghĩa thứ bậc. Tức là gì? Ví dụ là
số 3 phải lớn hơn số 2, số 2 phải lớn
hơn số 1 đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn có
thông tin này về về về tuổi đi đúng
không? 18 tuổi thì lớn hơn 16 tuổi. 16
tuổi phải lớn hơn 10 tuổi đúng không?
Nhưng mà số điện thoại không có mối quan
hệ như vậy. Số điện thoại các bạn không
thể nào các bạn bảo cái số này lớn hơn
số kia đúng không? Không ai đi lại không
ai lại đi so hai số điện thoại xem là số
nào lớn hơn số nào đúng không? Số điện
thoại không có ý nghĩa lớn nhỏ, không có
ý nghĩa thứ bậc đúng không? Đấy là một
cái ví dụ hoặc là ví dụ về mã vùng đ ví
dụ là cái mã vùng biển số xe ấy đúng
không? Ở Hà Nội là 2930 chẳng hạn đúng
không? Ờ 2930 31 gì đấy đúng không? Ở Hồ
Chí Minh là 50 51 52 nhưng mà không ai
người ta bảo là biển Hồ Chí Minh lớn hơn
biển Hà Nội cả. Tại vì cái cái số đấy nó
chù để nó để nó phân biệt giữa vùng này
với vùng kia thôi đúng không? Đấy thì
đấy là cái ví dụ của những cái feature
mà về hình thức trông nó y hệt là
numerical feature nhưng nó lại không
phải là numerical feature. Được chưa?
Thì đấy là cái loại đầu tiên là
numerical feature nghĩa thu tính đúng
không ạ? Số t gì hình thức nó là số và ý
nghĩa nó cũng là số luôn. Được chưa? Cái
loại thứ hai người ta gọi là categorical
feature. Categorical feature là những
thuộc tính dạng phân loại.
Thế thì trong categorical feature ấy lại
phân ra làm ba loại khác nhau. Loại đầu
tiên người ta gọi là nominal. À thì các
bạn chú ý này, với num feature ấy thì
nhìn chung các bạn sẽ có rất là nhiều
giá trị khác nhau. Thế thậm chí là vô
số. Còn trong khi với categor các bạn sẽ
có hữu hạn giá trị khác nhau và các bạn
có thể đếm được xem là có bao nhiêu. Thế
thì trong categore.
Nominal feature là thuộc tính định
thuộc tính định danh. Nominal fure được
tính định danh. Định danh có nghĩa là
gì? Ví dụ các bạn có những thông tin ví
dụ như là quốc tịch đúng không? Vô tịch
Mỹ, Việt Nam, Canada, Campuchia, Lào,
Hàn Quốc, Nhật Bản, Pháp đúng không? Thì
với thu định danh này đúng không? Các
bạn vẫn là có hữu hạn giá trị khác nhau
và giữa các cái giá trị này hoàn toàn
bình đẳng đến nhau về mặt ý nghĩa đúng
không? Mỹ, New Zealand, Hàn Quốc, Việt
Nam các thứ đ hoàn toàn bình đẳng nhau.
Không có ông nào lớn hơn ông nào, không
có ông nào nhỏ hơn ông nào đúng không?
Thế đấy là nominal feature. Cái lại con
thứ hai đó là ordinal feature. Ordin
Feature là tính dạng định lượng chưa bạn
xem các em? Không phải định lượng cái gì
nhỉ? or t th nhưng nó có thứ tự thì nó
có thứ tự có thứ tự tức là gì có thứ tự
có nghĩa là bây giờ ví dụ các bạn có
kích thước quần áo đi xs ml xl đi đúng
không rõ ràng là các bạn có hữ vận giá
trị khác nhau nó không phải là số nhưng
mà giữa chúng tồn tại một cái thứ bậc gì
đấy hoặc là bây giờ các bạn đi ăn ở quán
chẳng hạn đúng không sau các bạn ăn xong
thì các bạn sẽ có một cái phiếu đánh giá
đúng không rất hài lòng không hài lòng
bình thường hài lòng rất hài lòng thì
đấy cũng là một cái ví dụ của ordinal
feature tức là gì nó là categorical nó
có hư thứ hợp giá trị khác nhau và giữa
các cái giá trị này nó tồn tại một cái
thứ bậc, một cái order gì đấy đúng
không? Giữa chúng tồn tại một cái thứ
bậc, một cái order gì đấy.
Cái thứ tự này nó có thể là tăng dần,
giảm dần, bé dần, lớn dần, tồi dần, tốt
dần, xấu dần, đẹp dần không quan trọng
nhưng mà giữa chúng là phải có một cái
thứ bậc. Được chưa? Cái đấy là loại thứ
hai là loại original. Thường với các bạn
mới học các bạn sẽ hay bị nhầm giữa
nominal với original. Đấy, một ông là có
thứ bậc, một ông thì không có. Được
chưa? Cái loại thứ ba là bulin. Bullin
là những cái feature mà các bạn chỉ có
hai giá trị thôi. Yes hoặc là no, true
hoặc là phone, đúng hoặc là sai, nam
hoặc là nữ. Đấy là ví dụ của bullying.
Thế đấy là những cái loại phổ biến nhất
đúng không? Numerical feature và
categoryical feature.
Thế ngoài ra nó còn có một cái một vài
cái loại nữa ví dụ như là cái dạng dạng
kiểu nhãn thời gian kiểu time stamp.
Nhãn thời gian thì ở những cái buổi sau
chúng ta khi chúng ta làm về bài toán
time safe casting mình sẽ nói thêm nhá.
nhãn thời gian này rồi các loại là theo
kiểu khoản nữa nhưng mà nhìn chung là
numerical với cả categorical là hai loại
phổ biến nhất
rồi. Ok. Đến đây có câu hỏi gì không?
Why có thắc mắc gì không?
Any questions?
Ok. Không ai có câu hỏi gì nhá. Tiếp
nhá.
Thế thế chúng ta nói về các cái loại
feature phổ biến trong dữ liệu dạng bảng
đúng không? Dây dọa bảng như này đúng
không? Dây dọa bảng như này. Được chưa?
Thế thì
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau nói về một
vài những cái thuật ngữ nhá. Chúng ta sẽ
nói về một vài những cái thuật ngữ mà
các bạn cần nắm được với cái dự bảng này
đúng không? Trước giờ chúng ta chỉ nói
là thay đa thôi. Thế nhưng mà chúng ta
sẽ có cả những cái thứ chi tiết hơn nữa
đúng không? Cụ thể là gì? Cụ thể là bây
giờ với với mỗi một cái hàng nhá. Mỗi
một cái hàng chúng sẽ gọi tên là gì? Mỗi
một cái hàng chúng sẽ có gọi đây là nó
là một sample là mẫu đấy. Một object,
một đối tượng đúng không? Một record,
một bản ghi, một item. Item chả biết t
viên Việt gọi là gì nhỉ? Item gọi là
phần tử đúng không? Hoặc là một
observation. Một quan sát đ nó có rất
nhiều tên đúng không? Simple, object,
record, item observation. Rất nhiều cách
khác nhau để gọi một hàng thế này. Được
chưa? Thì đây là một hàng. Thế còn với
mỗi một cột thì với những cái cột mà
không phải cái cột mà chúng ta cần phải
dự đoán ấy thì chúng ta gọi nó là một
feature hoặc là một attribute. Feature
thì là đặc trưng. Attribute thì là thuộc
tính được chưa? Còn cái cột mà chúng ta
muốn một mình dự đoán ấy thì người ta
gọi nó là target là mục tiêu hoặc là
label gọi là nhãn. Được chưa? Đây là một
vài cái thuật ngữ. Đây một vài những cái
thuật ngữ bạn nhá. Có tài liệu dùng
thuật ngữ này, có tài liệu dùng thuật
ngữ kia. Nên ở đây mình liên kê cho các
bạn tất cả những thuật ngữ mà phổ biến
nhất. Phổ biến nhất.
Tiếp nhá các bạn. Nhìn này. Một hàng thì
gọi là một sample. Thì nếu chúng ta bây
giờ chúng ta chỉ lấy cái phần mà không
liên quan đến cái target ấy thì chúng ta
sẽ gọi nó là một feature vector. Được
chưa? Ví dụ cái target là cái cột price
này. Bây giờ mình bỏ cột price đi đúng
không? Thì nó sẽ nó là một cái gì? Nó là
một cái feature vector đúng không? Nó là
một cái feature vector. Feature vector
chính là cái input mà chúng ta sẽ đưa
vào trong mô hình để mô hình nó dự đoán
nó đúng không? Nó chính là cái đề bài
đấy đúng không? Chúng ta phải chúng ta
phải xóa cái lời giải đi đúng không? Cho
người ta làm thì phải xóa cái lời giải
đi chứ bây giờ cho cả lời giải vào thì
còn gì mà dự đoán nữa đúng không? Xóa
cái lời giải đi đúng không? Cho cái
input đầu vào thôi. Đây chính là cái bài
tập đầu vào của bạn đấy. Đúng không? bài
tập của các bạn mà cô cho hàng ngày đấy
đúng không? Đây gọi là một feature
vector. Được chưa? Các bạn chú ý này,
trong trường hợp diệu dọ bảng ấy thì cái
này gọi là một feature vector. Thế nhưng
mà trong sự ví dụ dạng ảnh á thì người
ta sẽ không gọi là vecơ đâu. Tại vì
trong ảnh nó sẽ có nhiều chiều hơn. Được
chưa? Thế mà hiện tại các bạn đang làm
việc với rượu dạng bảng thì các bạn chỉ
biết thế này thôi. Được chưa? Đây là một
feature vector.
Tiếp này. Thế bây giờ đến đây có bào có
câu hỏi gì nữa không? Đến đây có ai có
câu hỏi gì không? Có ai có câu hỏi gì về
các cái thuân ngữ này không?
nhá. Thì bây giờ chúng ta tiếp thêm một
phần nữa chúng ta nghỉ giải các bạn nhá.
Tiếp một phần nữa này. Thì bây giờ chúng
ta sẽ nói về việc là phân chia dữ liệu.
Các bạn chú ý này, trong AI, trong
machining, trong link nhìn chung ấy khi
mà chúng ta có dữ liệu, chúng ta sẽ
không bao giờ dùng toàn bộ, không bao
giờ dùng tất cả dữ liệu dùng để huấn
luyện mô hình. Tại vì sao? Tại vì nếu mà
các bạn dùng toàn bộ dữ liệu để huấn
luyện mô hình thì tí nữa các bạn sẽ
chẳng còn gì để có thể đánh giá mô hình
nữa đúng không? Cũng giống như kiểu cô
giáo ngày xưa ấy, cô có bao nhiêu đề cô
cũng phải giữ một ít để cô làm đề thi
chứ chứ làm gì có chuyện cô cho các bạn
đi làm hết đúng không? Thì thông thường
ấy khi mà chúng ta có một bộ dữ liệu
chúng ta sẽ phải phân chia bộ dữ liệu
này ra thành ba tập con. Một tập thì gọi
là chuyên set, một tập gọi là validation
set và một tập gọi là test set. Được
chưa? Ba tập này nó đóng vai trò như thế
nào? Ba tập này nó có ý nghĩa như sau.
Đầu tiên là chuyên xét. Đây là tập dữ
liệu huấn luyện. Huấn luyện đây là tập
dữ liệu nó sẽ trực tiếp nó giúp cải
thiện performance của mô hình. Cái tập
liệu huấn luyện này ấy nó cũng tương
đương với cái sách vở, những cái tài
liệu, những cái giáo trình mà ngày xưa
hàng ngày cô giáo cho các bạn học ấy
đúng không? Hàng ngày cô cho các bạn học
cái gì thì đấy nó chính là cái chuyên
xét này. Được chưa? Cái chuyên xét này
bao giờ kích thước động lớn nhất? Bao
giờ trong ba bộ đây cũng là bộ lớn nhất
tại vì ngày xưa cái ngày xưa cái khối
lượng bài tập các bạn học hàng ngày nó
là nhiều nhất mà đúng không? Thì cái
ching set này nó sẽ trực tiếp dùng để
huấn luyện mô hình. Mô hình sẽ được cải
thiện performance. Tức là gì? Chúng sẽ
đưa cái chuyên set này vào trong mô
hình. Tất nhiên chúng ta chỉ đưa feature
vào thôi đúng không? Chúng ta phải bỏ
cái target đi đúng không? Đưa vào mô
hình. Mô hình đưa dự đoán. Dự đoán của
mô hình sẽ được so hình thành cái target
để xác định được cái loss. Loss ảnh
ngược lại update mô hình được chưa?
Giống như cái này chúng ta học nọ này.
Đấy nó nó như này. Đấy như này đúng
không? Dữ liệu đúng không? Bộ trin đưa
vào mô hình. Mình đ dự đoán dự đoán cho
anh với thực tế ra được thông qua cái
hàm mất mát ra được cái giá trị mất mát
rồi quay ngượ lại để cập nhật mô hình
đúng không thì cái bộ tr đúng như vậy
đúng không bộ train sẽ là thứ trực tiếp
giúp cho mô hình tốt hơn đúng không tại
vì chúng ta update là update dựa trên bộ
trade mà đấy thế thì trong cái trong cái
quá trình chúng ta trong cái quá trình
chúng ta huấn luyện mô hình ấy sẽ có
những cái thời điểm chúng ta sẽ phải
đánh giá xem là liệu quá trình huấn
luyện này nó có đang đi đúng hướng hay
không nó cũng giống như kiểu ngày xưa ấy
các bạn đi học cũng thế rồi đúng không
các bạn cứ học khoảng 3 4 tháng thì nhà
trường sẽ phải có cách để có thể đánh
giá xem là các bạn có đang học đúng hay
không. Thông qua cái gì các bạn nhỉ? Các
bạn cứ học 3 4 tháng thì giảng viên à
giáo viên và nhà trường sẽ phải đánh giá
xem liệu các bạn có đang học đúng hay
không, liệu các bạn có đang học được cái
gì hữi hay không, thông qua cái gì các
bạn
đến
>> thông qua cái gì?
>> Thi khảo sát chất lượng ạ.
Thông qua bài bài thi cuối kỳ giờ ơi.
>> Bài kiểm tra. Bài kiểm tra
>> đúng rồi. Bài kiểm tra bài thi cuối kỳ
đó. Bài thi cuối kỳ đúng học 3 4 tháng
các bạn đi thi cuối kỳ một lần mà đúng
không? Ai chả thế đúng không? Đúng
không? Thì với con người thế nào? Thì
đây cũng phải như vậy. Tại vì sao? Cô
giáo không thể nào dạy các bạn liền tù
tì 3 năm cấp ba mà không có cái bước
đánh giá gì đúng không? Nhỡ đâu các bạn
chả học được cái gì thì làm sao đúng
không? Cô phải đánh giá đúng không? Thì
đây cũng thế. Chúng ta cũng không thể
nào chúng ta huyện một mô hình mình cứ
để nó chạy mãi chạy mãi chạy mãi được mà
chúng ta cũng phải có cái đặng chúng ta
đánh giá đúng không? Thông thường ấy thì
cái quá trình h mô hình chúng ta sẽ phải
đưa cái bộ tren qua mô hình rất nhiều
lần nhá. Chúng ta sẽ phải đưa bộ tren
qua mô hình rất nhiều lần trong quá
trình huấn luyện. Thế thì thông thường
ấy cứ mỗi khi mà chúng ta đưa toàn bộ
trin này qua mô hình được một lần rồi.
Tất nhiên người ta sẽ không đưa kiểu đưa
hết vào một cục đâu. Ta sẽ phải chia nhỏ
ra tại vì là máy chúng ta nó cái cái cái
giới hạn mình cứng nó nó không có đáp
ứng được đúng không? Chúng ta phải chia
nhỏ cái bộ chuyên ra thành những cái
thành những cái tập con đúng không? Thì
mỗi khi nào chúng ta đưa hết toàn bộ bộ
trên này qua mô hình một một lần rồi,
chúng ta sẽ phải đánh giá xem là cái mô
hình này nó có học đúng hướng hay không.
Thì làm sao để đánh giá được? Thì lúc
này chúng ta sẽ cần một cái bộ thứ hai.
Cái bộ này gọi là bộ validation.
Validation set nó tương đương với cái
bài chá kiểm tra cuối kỳ. Các bạn nhìn
này, nhiệm vụ của cái bài kiểm tra cuối
kỳ không phải là để giúp cho các bạn học
tốt hơn, không phải là để giúp cho các
bạn giỏi hơn mà nhiệm vụ của bài thi
cuối kỳ là gì? là để cô giáo có thể đánh
giá được xem các bạn có đang học được
hướng hay không. Tại vì nếu các bạn đang
học được hướng thì càng ngày cái bài
kiểm tra cuối kỳ của bạn kết quả nó càng
phải tốt hơn so với lúc trước đúng
không? Đấy nhiệm vụ của bài thi cuối kỳ
không phải là để giúp cho các bạn tốt
hơn mà là để cô giáo đánh giá xem các
bạn có đang học đúng không hay không
đúng không? Thế cái quá trình nó cứ nó
cứ đan x như vậy thôi các bạn. Sau khi
các bạn đưa hết rượu của bộ tren qua mô
hình một lần thông thường người ta sẽ
đánh giá cái mô hình này với bộ viion sa
cứ lắp đi lại như vậy lắp đi lại như vậy
rất là nhiều lần đúng không? Cho đến khi
nào các bạn thấy một là các bạn hài lòng
với cái kết quả của mô hình, hai là cái
quá trình huấn luyện cái thời gian các
bạn setup đã hết rồi. Ví dụ các bạn sơ
học chỉ học 3 năm thôi đúng không? Học
hết 3 năm là phải đi thi rồi không học
nữa được đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ ấy
sau khi quá trình huấn luyện nó đã hoàn
toàn kết thúc rồi, sau khi chúng ta đảm
bảo là gì? Chúng ta sẽ hoàn toàn chúng
ta sẽ không update, không cập nhật mô
hình nữa. Thì sau đó chúng ta sẽ phải
đánh giá mô hình của chúng ta lần cuối.
Đánh giá mô hình lần cuối để làm gì?
chúng ta có thể đem đi public, đem đi
chia sẻ đúng không? Các bạn nhìn này,
cái bộ validation ấy có thể dùng để để
có thể check, có thể theo dõi cái tiến
bộ của bạn thì được nhưng mà cái bộ
trình này sẽ không dùng để so sánh bạn
này với bạn kia được. Tại vì sao? Có thể
hoàn toàn là hai bạn ở hai lớp khác
nhau. Các bạn có hai cái bài kiểm tra
khác nhau đúng không? Thì không thể nào
bảo là cái bạn 9 điểm, tôi là bạn tám
điểm rồi. Tại vì là gì? Bộ variation
chắc gì nó giống nhau đúng không? bài
thi cuối kỳ gì giống nhau. Thế bây giờ
muốn đánh giá, muốn so sánh hai học sinh
bất kỳ với nhau ấy đúng không? Thì thứ
nhất là gì? Là phải chờ khi họ học xong
rồi đúng không? Học xong rồi hoàn toàn
không update cái gì nữa đúng không? Thì
lúc này tôi mới so sánh giữa hai môi với
nhau hay tôi so sánh giữa hai bạn học
sinh với nhau đúng không? Và để so sánh
được hai học sinh một cách nhất chúng ta
sẽ dựa vào bài thi tốt nghiệp trung học
phổ thông đúng không? Dựa vào bài thi t
chu phổ thông để đánh giá hai hay nhiều
học sinh một cách công bằng nhất đúng
không? Lúc này đề là đề chung đúng
không? Thì đấy chính là cái vai trò của
bộ test. Sau khi các bạn huấn luyện xong
hết rồi các bạn sẽ đánh giá mô hình lần
cuối với bộ test. Và lúc này cái
performance của mô hình với bộ test này
ấ chính là cái performance mà các bạn sẽ
public lên cái bài báo là các bạn công
bố với sếp với khách hàng đúng không?
Performance của mô hình nó tốt hay nó
tồi thế nào là các bạn sẽ đánh giá dựa
trên bộ test này. Được chưa? Không ai đi
khoe là con tôi được 9 điểm 10 điểm cuối
kỳ cả mà phải khoe là gì? Con tới 9 điểm
10 điểm thi thúc theo chu phổ thông đúng
không? Điển thị cuối kỳ nh trường bạn là
trường dễ trường ghi trường khó đúng
không? Làm sao mà so sánh được đúng
không? Phải so sánh dựa trên một cái bài
test chung đúng không? Đó chính là bài
thi tố nghiệp chu phổ thông. Thế tức là
gì? Bộ trang tương ứng với tài liệu các
bạn học hàng ngày. Bộ variation là bài
thi cuối kỳ. Bộ test là bài thi tốt
nghiệp thu phổ thông đúng không? Chúng
ta chỉ đánh giá mô hình trên bộ test khi
nào chúng ta đã hoàn toàn kết thúc quá
trình huấn luyện rồi, chúng ta không cập
nhật mô hình nữa. Thì đấy là ý nghĩa của
ba bộ này. Thông thường ba bộ này nó có
một vài những cái tỉ lệ phổ biến sau.
Thứ nhất là 60 20 hoặc là 70 15 hoặc là
70 20 10 hoặc là 80 10 hoặc là 90 55.
Thông thường thì bộ test và bộ va kích
thước nó sẽ thường nó sẽ bằng nhau. Nó
sẽ bé hơn rất là nhiều so với với bộ
trên.
Ờ
thông thường thế này, thông thường người
ta sẽ có cái xu hướng là gì? Là người ta
sẽ dành cái tỉ lệ cho bộ trên nhiều hơn
khi mà số lượng dữ liệu ít. Số lượng dữ
liệu mà ít người ta sẽ chia cho bộ trên
nhiều hơn. Ví dụ dữ liệu mà rất ít người
ta sẽ có thể chia ra 80 10 hoặc là chia
905. Thế còn khi mà rượu nó rất là nhiều
người ta sẽ chia cho hai bộ kia nhiều
hơn. Ví dụ như là 60 20 hoặc là 70 15
chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy.
Rồi ok nhớ nhá. Cái này nó áp dụng cho
cho
tất cả mọi bài toán nhá. Không thể nào
có chuyện là dùng toàn bộ dữ liệu để có
thể huấn luyện mô hình được. Phải dành
ra một ít để sau này tôi còn có kiểm tra
chứ đúng không? Rồi. Ok. Có bạn nào có
câu hỏi gì không?
Có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì về ý nghĩa của ba
bộ này nữa không?
Ok. Thế nếu không ai có câu hỏi gì chúng
ta nghỉ giải lao tại chỗ 5 phút các bạn
nhá. Các bạn muốn hỏi gì các bạn cứ hỏi
nhá. Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi nhá.
Mình vẫn ngồi trước máy thôi nhá. Mình
đọc báo một tí.
mình sẽ phải xử lý dữ liệu thôi. Còn cái
còn cái kia nó liên quan đến các bạn
data engineer nhiều hơn nhá. mình sẽ xử
lý dữ liệu nhưng mà còn EDA thì nó còn
bên DAT nhiều hơn
không xin hỏi trong một bản dữ liệu thì
các feature Hv nó sẽ luôn liên quan đến
tit không có thể có những cái feature nó
chả liên quan gì đúng không nó phụ thuộc
vào cái người thu hợp dữ liệu đúng không
hoàn toàn có khả năng là người ta thu
nhng cái dữ liệu dư thừa nó không liên
quan gì đúng không nhiệm vụ của data
cent là gì là phải loại bỏ được những
cái dữ liệu dư thừa như vậy
có chứ vẫn có chứ có chứ trong quá trình
học chúng ta sẽ làm nhá vẫn có những cái
thống kê để chúng tôi đánh ra xem là cái
nào quan trọng
H
H á
cái hồi mình mới ra trường hồi đấy mình
có chóp rồi nhưng mà mình tại vì À mình
ở Đức thì à tiếng Đức thì mình không có,
tiếng Anh thì mình cũng không có giỏi
tiếng Anh hơn những người khác. Lập
trình thì đấy mình cũng mới ra trường
thôi. Mình nghĩ là mình sẽ cần có một
cái điểm nhấn gì đấy để có một cái điểm
nhấn gì đấy khác biệt với những người
khác. Thì hồi đấy mình nhắm đến
KitHub. Tại vì mình thấy là hầu hết mọi
người git hub chỉ mở ra là để là cái nơi
để các bạn ờ for các bạn clone report về
thôi. Mình thấy ít người ta sử dụng cái
tài khoản Ghub mà có các cái project nó
tốt. Sau đấy mình tập trung vào mình xây
dựng thôi thì mình có cái ý mình có cái
ý tưởng gì hay thì mình xây dựng xong
mình chia sẻ lên Facebook, trên Reddit,
trên Linkin kiểu như vậy. Thì mình chia
từ 2018 rồi thì nó mới thì nó thì nó như
thế này. Bây giờ thì để nó sẽ khó hơn
tại vì bây giờ các cái project mà muốn
được dành được sự chú ý của cộng đồng ấy
thì nó phải nó phải rất là rất là đặc
biệt. Nhưng mà ngày xưa những cái
project này của mình th ý tưởng cũng
không hẳn là của mình. Mình thấy là có
những cái tức là những người ta làm ý
những cái ý tưởng này nhưng mà người ta
không chia sẻ mã nguồn thì mình làm theo
cái ý hiểu của mình thôi. Ví dụ cái
quick draw này. Mình không phải người
đầu tiên mình làm cái này. Người người
ta làm rồi nhưng mà người ta không chia
sẻ mã nguồn. Bây giờ mình tự làm thôi.
Bạn chển load
đây này. Mình làm 2018 này.
Này công ty đầu tiên của mình sau khi ra
trường này.
Bây giờ mà các bạn làm những cái project
này thì chắc là chả qua người ta người
ta git star cho các bạn đâu. Nhưng mà
thời ngày xưa thì lại có
[khịt mũi]
Linkin thì cứ mỗi một ngày xưa mình cứ
mỗi ngày mình c add 30 người làm về data
làm về machining. Thế là khoảng hơn 1
năm thì cái mặn ớ của mình nó rất là lớn
rồi. Sau người ta tự kết nối với mình.
Record nó record nó chỉ có màn hình
chính thôi. Anh sẽ cố gắng là nếu mà có
ai hỏi thì anh sẽ đọc lại câu hỏi nhá.
Nó chỉ có màn hình chính thôi. Tại vì
cái màn hình chat lại ở màn hình khác
rồi. Bây giờ mà record cả hai cái thì
cái màn hình chính lại bé đi.
Ok.
>> Việt ơi Việt có chia sẻ trên kí hub một
cái giáo trình machine learning cơ bản
của Vũ Hữu Tiệp ấy.
>> Dạ.
>> Đấy có mình có nên đọc không? Quyển đấy
hay mà anh quyển đấy là quyển đấy là
chất là chắc là đấy là quyển tài liệu về
machining bằng tiếng Việt nổi tiếng nhất
ở Việt Nam rồi anh Tiệp làm quyển đấy
chi tiết lắm thấy hay anh ạ
cũng hay tất cả những cái mà Việt đang
chia sẻ và những cái kiến thức trong này
đều nó liên quan hết với nhau đúng
không?
Bây giờ thì nó tức là những cái những
cái thứ mà em thấy là những thứ em nhìn
thấy người ta chia sẻ trên Linkin em xem
có cái nào nó liên quan đến cái mảng của
mình hay không hoặc là cái gì mình thấy
em thấy thú vị không thì em chia sẻ cho
mọi người. Thế nhưng mà tất nhiên cũng
có cái nguồn nó sẽ hữu ích nhiều và cái
nguồn nó hữu ích ít. Nhưng mà
>> không ý ý mình là là cái bài giảng của
Việt đây này.
>> Cái nội dung bài giảng của Việt và cái
nội dung trong cái quyến sách này nó sẽ
nhiều nó sẽ tương đồng đúng không? Vâng
vâng vâng. Tại vì đều là mering màạ.
Ok
tiếp mọi người nhá. Thế cách vừa rồi ấy
là cách phân chia tiêu chuẩn đúng không?
Phân chia tiêu chuẩn là gì? Là phân chia
ra ba bộ train và set. Các bạn chú ý
nhá. Các bạn phải đảm bảo gì? Là ba cái
bộ này nó không overlap với nhau. Tức là
gì? Tức là một sample nó đã vào bộ train
thì nó không thể nào vào bộ version hoặc
là bộ test được đúng không? Không bao
giờ có chuyện là hai bộ lại bị trùng
nhau ở một cái chỗ nào đấy. Được chưa?
Ba cái này là non overlapping. Được
chưa?
Và một cái nữa là gì? Nếu các bạn muốn
mô hình học cách hiệu quả ấy các bạn
phải đảm bảo gì? Là cái phân bố của dữ
liệu hay là cái data distribution của bộ
train, bộ vộ test nó phải tương đương
nhau. Nó cũng giống như kiểu này. Bây
giờ các bạn muốn một cái đứa trẻ nó đi
thi tốt được đúng không? Bài thi nó sẽ
có đạo hàm, tích phân, khảo sát hàm số,
hình học, lượng giác, số phức đúng
không? Thì lúc quá trình học ấy nó cũng
phải đủ những cái dạng bài đấy chứ còn
nếu các bạn theo kiểu là bộ chuyên thì
toàn câu đạo hàm, bộ test lại toàn câu
lượng giác chẳng hạn thì môi nó sẽ không
học được đúng không? Con người như thế
nào thì máy nó phải y như thế. Muốn máy
móc nó làm được cái gì thì phải huấn
luyện nó với đúng cái dữ liệu đấy. Được
chưa? Nên các bạn phải đảm bảo là cái
cái phân bố của dữ liệu nó tương đương
nhau trong ba cái bộ này. Tránh cái việc
là nó lệch tức là bộ chuyên thì toàn cái
này, bộ test thì toàn cái kia. Được
chưa?
Tiếp nhá.
Thế ờ
chúng ta sẽ nói qua một chút về quá
trình chúng ta tiền xử lý dữ liệu.
Tiền dữ liệu tức là gì? Tức là cái dữ
liệu của chúng ta ấy chúng ta sẽ không
thể nào chúng ta đưa vào hỏng thẳng mô
hình được. Tại vì trong nhiều trường hợp
là dữ liệu chúng ta nó không phải là
chiếu dạng số đúng không? Dạng số thì
đưa vào mô hình được nhưng mà dữ liệu mà
chưa vẻ số thì chúng ta sẽ chưa có thể
đưa vào đưa vào mô hình được. Và ngoài
ra ấy thì kể cả dữ liệu ban đầu nó có là
dữ liệu dạng số rồi ấy thì nhưng mà
chúng ta vẫn sẽ nên chúng ta sao chúng
ta có thể xử lý theo cách nào để cho cái
rượu này nó sẽ thuận lợi hơn cho mô hình
trong việc học nhá. Thuận lợi hơn cho mô
hình trong việc học. Như vậy các bạn
nhìn này.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Thế nhìn chung là gì?
Chúng ta sẽ huấn luyện mô hình với không
phải là toàn bộ dữ liệu mà chỉ là với bộ
trin thôi đúng không? Bộ trin là cái bộ
mà sẽ trực tiếp chữ nhiện là chúng ta
dùng to huấn luyện mô hình đúng không?
Mô hình sẽ càng ngày nó càng tốt hơn,
giỏi hơn là nhờ vào bộ tren này đúng
không? Nhờ vào bộ tren này. Thế chúng ta
dùng rượu cho bộ tren đúng không? Tất
nhiên chúng tôi phải bỏ cái nhãn đi.
Nhãn nhét vào cuối đúng không? Nhét vào
cuối này đúng không? Chúng ta đưa cái đồ
vào đưa vào mô hình. Mô hình đưa dự đoán
dự đoán sang viên thực tế ra được cái
loss. Lost chúng ta tính ra được cái
lost value. Quay ngược lại cập nhật mô
hình. Xong được chưa? Cái quá trình nó
cứ lập đi lại như vậy. Liệu lập đi lại
vậy. Giống kiểu ngày xưa các bạn đi học
thế thôi. Ngày nào các bạn chả đến đến
lớp đúng không? Ngày nào cô chú các bạn
bài. Ngày nào các bạn chả làm bài xong
cô chữa bài, cô trả bài chữa cho các bạn
đúng không? Ngày hôm sau các bạn lại lặp
lại như vậy mà với là bài khác đúng
không? Thì đây nó cũng y chang như vậy.
Cách huấn luyện mô hình trong này nó
giống y chang cách chúng ta học ngày xưa
vậy đúng không? Đấy
đấy là quá trình chúng ta huấn luyện.
Thế còn khi chúng ta muốn đánh giá mô
hình chúng ta đánh giá sẽ có hai lúc
đánh giá. Một là đánh giá trong quá
trình huấn luyện là chúng ta sẽ dùng bộ
variation. Còn cái thứ hai nữa là đây là
đánh giá sau quá trình huấn luyện là
chúng ta sẽ dùng bộ test được chưa? Bộ
variation nó giống như cái bài thi cuối
kỳ vậy đúng không? Các bạn sẽ dùng trong
quá trình học ở những cái giai đoạn cụ
thể.
Còn bộ test là xong xuôi hết rồi thì tôi
mới dùng đến nó. Được chưa? Bộ test là
xong xuôi hết rồi tôi mới dùng nó tôi
đánh giá mô hình lần cuối. Được chưa?
Thì bây giờ cái các bạn nhìn này. Khi mà
mình đánh giá mô hình ấy thì mình sẽ
không có cái bước cập nhật nữa đúng
không? Đánh giá là không cập nhật đúng
không? Chỉ có huấn luyện thì mới cập
nhật thôi. Đánh giá thì không cập nhật
cái gì cả. Được chưa? Đánh giá nó sẽ ra
một cái magic giống kiểu là các bạn đi
thi cuối kỳ về đi thi chủ phổ thông ấy
đúng không? Làm gì có chuyện là là trả
bài về để cập nhật bản thân đâu. Không
có. Nó chỉ dùng để đánh giá các bạn thôi
đúng không? Đấy.
Thế bây gi các bạn nhìn này. Ở đây nó sẽ
có hai thứ khác biệt. Một là lost value
đúng không? Là giá trị mất mát và hai là
magic. Được chưa chưa? Lost value và
magic. Thì hai cái thứ này nó khác nhau
như thế nào?
Hai cái này đều dùng để đánh giá sự sai
lệch, sự khác biệt giữa dự đoán của mô
hình với giá trị thực tế. Nhưng mà cái
sự khác biệt ở chỗ là gì? Là loss chúng
ta dùng trong quá trình huấn luyện ở
những giai đoạn cụ thể mà cụ thể là trên
cái bộ variation đó đúng không? Và chúng
ta cũng dùng trong quá trình huấn luyện
nữa để chúng ta ra cái loss. Los có
nghĩa là update mô hình mà đúng không?
Tức là cái loss này sẽ dùng trong quá
trình huấn luyện mô hình đúng không? Còn
magic là dùng sau khi quá trình huấn
luyện nó đã kết thúc rồi thì chúng ta
mới dùng magic đúng không? Mặc dù về
hình thức hai ông có thể gần như là
giống yệt nhau tại vì là đều dùng để
đánh giá sự sai lệch giữa thực tế với dự
đoán mà đúng không? Ví dụ là gì? Hàng
ngày cô chấm cho các bạn điểm 9 điểm 10
ấy. Cái đấy nó là lost. Tất nhiên nó hơi
khác một chút là lost nó càng thấp càng
tốt chứ còn điểm càng càng càng tốt.
Nhưng mà đấy cái hàng ngày cô chấm cho
bạn ấy hàng ngày cô đánh giá cái bài của
bạn với cái đề cái cái bài đáp án ấy
thông qua cái cái điểm ấy đúng không?
Thì điểm nó tương đương với LOS. Còn cái
điểm thi cái điểm thi ví dụ điểm thi
cuối kỳ hay là điểm thi tốt nghiệp chu
phổ thông ấy thì nó là magic. Nó là
magic tại vì là nó không dùng để update
mô hình đúng không? Raia điểm thì là
xong không dùng quay ngược lại để update
để cải thiện mô hình. Được chưa? Đây cái
sự khác biệt giữa L với Magic đúng
không? Tức là gì? Chúng nó có thể là
hình thức nó sẽ giống nhau nhưng mà mục
đích sử dụng nó sẽ khác nhau. Đấy là nó
có tên gọi khác nhau như này. Được chưa?
Lost v magic.
Rồi các bạn đến đây ai có câu hỏi gì
không?
còn tiêu hóa được không các bạn?
>> Có nghĩa là cái lot này mình sẽ dùng
trong quá trình change và validation.
Còn cái matric mình dùng trong quá trình
sau đó là cái bước cuối cùng là test
đúng không ạ?
>> Vâng đúng rồi. Tức là kết quả nó có thể
nó giống yệt nhau. Công thức nó có thể
giống yệt nhau nhưng cách gọi nó sẽ
khác. Hiểu như thế
>> dạ đế là chính xác
nhá. Los và magic. L và dùng trong quá
trình huấn luyện. Còn Magic là xong rồi.
Xong rồi thì mình magic nhá. Dạ. Cho em
hỏi là ví dụ mà một vài cái mô hình mà
nó không có cái hàm mất mát, không có
hàm loss thì mình dùng cái gì để đánh
giá nó?
>> Mô hình mà không có m chúng ta cũng khỏi
đánh giá luôn. Nó nó không có gì đánh
giá cả. Ví dụ có mấy bài toán mà em thấy
về ví dụ như là dự đoán rủi ro cái frow
detection á là người ta tập trung để kéo
cái reco.
Thì
cái việc là tại nãy anh nói là những cái
matric như là precision hay recall thì
nó chỉ dùng trên tập test thôi. Nhưng mà
tức là ví dụ mình mình phải xem là trên
những cái tập validation nó bao nhiêu đó
xong rồi mình có mục tiêu là mình muốn
đẩy nó lên bao nhiêu.
>> Có version cũng có
cũng có mà đánh giá giữa dự đoán với
giữa thực tế là các bạn ra được mà
>> tức là mình vẫn sẽ áp dụng những cái
magic trên tập validation bình thường mà
đúng không?
>> Chúng ta có thể áp dụng tại vì nó chỉ
đơn giản là gì? Nó dùng để nó đánh giá
xem cái dán của mô hình thôi. Nó chỉ
đánh giá nó không update cái gì cả. Thế
là nó
>> đấy cái bài toán đấy muốn muốn có cái dự
đoán đấy là nó phải qua ló rồi không thể
nào trong quá trình huấn luyện lại không
có l được không có l thì không thể ra
được cái dự đoán được đúng không tức
không phải tức là không có l thì sẽ
không có cơ chế gì để so sánh giữa thư
tới với dự đoán cả đúng không phải có
loss
l thứ trực tiếp chúng ta dùng chúng ta
so sánh giữa tức là nó là kết quả của
cái khi mà chúng ta so sánh giữa thực tế
với dự đoán là nó ra l trong quá trình
huấn luyện ấy
rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì nữa
Nào thử nghĩ kỹ xem nào. Mình không muốn
đi nhanh nhanh nhanh nhanh trong khi các
bạn không nắm chắc không có chỗ nào các
bạn thấy chưa clear các bạn cứ hỏi thoải
mái.
Ok thoải mái không phải giơ tay đâu.
Thoải mái nữa. Mình cứ bật mic thôi. Ờ
dạ em xin phép hỏi thầy chút là cái
trong quá trình trên ấy ạ thì sau khi có
lost rồi thì mình tức là nó biết được
khoảng cách giữa cái kết quả với cả cái
dự đoán ban đầu. nó lệch nhau rồi thì
cái việc cải thiện đấy là mình phải
nhúng tay vào cải thiện hay là máy nó sẽ
tự xem xét lại để nó cải thiện
>> nó sẽ có cái công thức để nó cải thiện
mỗi thời gian khác nhau công thức khác
nhau nhưng mình không phải làm thủ công
đâu. Không phải làm thủ công đâu. Nó sẽ
tự cập nhật.
>> Vậy là mỗi model nó sẽ có một công thức
nhạ. Sau này khi mà chúng ta học về deep
link sẽ nói sâu hơn về cái việc là nó
update như thế nào. Thế nhưng mà hiện
tại các bạn hiểu gì? thì mỗi đồ toàn nó
sẽ có cách cơ chế khác nhau để nó có thể
update.
Và trong bài toán classification thì
lots nó sẽ là cross entropy loss nhá.
Trong bài toán classification cái loss
của nó sẽ là cross entropy loss. Rồi các
có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Ok tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá. Tiếp này.
Thế bây giờ chúng ta sẽ nói kỹ hơn. về
phản ân m hay là lost function không?
Nói kỹ hơn về hảm ơn m hay là l function
các bạn nhìn nhá. Thế thì này chúng ta
hãy nói về bài toán regression trước đi
đúng không? Bài toán regression ví dụ
các bạn đang sử dụng cái mô hình dành
cho bài toán dự đoán giá nhà đúng không?
Thì giá nhà là một cái giá trị nằm trong
một cái giải liên tục và các bạn sẽ có
vô số giá vô số giá trị khác nhau nên
đây là bài toán reaction. Thì cái magic
đầu tiên người ta gọi là min absolute
arrot nhá. Min absolute er hay viết tắt
là mae. Min absolute er bằng gì? Rất là
đơn giản thôi. Nó bằng trung bình cộng
của các cái sai lệch thôi đúng không?
Sai lệch là gì? Nó sẽ thấy giá trị thực
tế trừ đi giá trị dự đoán sau đó đóng
một cái trị tuyệt đối vào đúng không?
Thực tế trừ đi dự đoán sau đó đóng trị
tuyệt đối vào cộng với trung bình lại
chia cho chia cho n với n là số lượng
sle. Xong được chưa? Đây là min up số
lượng ar. Cách thứ hai là gì? Cách thứ
hai người ta đọc là min mean min square
arrow. Min square root có nghĩa gì? Tức
là bây giờ về mỗi một cái sai l người ta
sẽ bình phương lên cộng hết vào với nhau
sau đó chia cho tổng số lượng sle đúng
không? Một ông là bậc 1, ông là bậc hai.
Đấy, hai này nó chỉ khác biệt giữa gì?
Là một ông bậc 1 và một ông bậc hai
thôi. Được chưa? Cái khóa trước thì mình
sẽ ghi công thức và khóa này thì mình
thấy là dụng hình ảnh nó dễ dễ nhìn hơn
các bạn nhìn nhá. Nếu mà nói về công
thức này, công thức này
cái này một ông bậc 1 bậc hai đây.
Đâu rồi?
Đây đúng không?
Min áp suú là bậc 1, min square là bậc
2. Được chưa?
Được chưa?
Đúng không? Cái này nó khác biệt nhau
như nào? Cái ông min square ấy nó sẽ
khuếch đại những cái size số lớn
hơn. Tức là gì? Bình thường nhá. Với min
absur er ấy đúng không? Một căn nhà dự
đoán size 10 triệu thì nó nghiêm trọng
tương đương với 10 căn size 1 triệu.
Nhưng mà với min square ấy thì một căn
size 10 triệu nó sẽ nghiêm trọng tương
đương với 100 căn size 1 triệu. Được
chưa? Tức là với min square nó sẽ khuếch
đại những cái size số lớn. Size số càng
lớn nó càng khuếch đại lên. Thế thì cái
mô hình nào mà chúng ta dùng cái hàm lót
là min square ấy thì nó sẽ có cái xu
hướng là gì? Là nó sẽ tập trung vào
những cái size số lớn nhiều hơn. Tại vì
size số lớn là cái thành phần nó khiến
cho lót nó lớn đúng không? Size số lớn
là thành phần nó khiến cho lót nó tăng
lên nhiều đúng không? Mà à một cái nữa
cái nữa chư là mình quên mình thôi các
bạn các bạn nhá phải nói từ buổi hôm
trước các bạn nhìn này nhá một cái điểm
rất là quan trọng là gì tức là ấy bình
thường ấy khi mà trong khi mà trong
machining ấy người ta hay nói là người
ta hay nói là tối ưu hóa mô hình đúng
không? Trong người ta hay nói là gì? Là
tôi huấn luyện mô hình, tôi tối ưu hóa
mô hình. Thì các bạn hiểu này, khi mà
người ta nói là tối hóa mô hình ý thì
thực chất cái mà người ta đang nhắm đến
là gì? Là người ta đang muốn tối thiểu
hóa hàm loss nhá. Đúng không? Khi mà các
nói là tôi huấn luyện mô hình này, tôi
tối ưu hóa mô hình thì thật ra cái mà
chúng ta đang muốn làm là chúng ta đang
muốn tối thiểu hóa cái hàm loss, đúng
không? Cái thứ mà chúng ta trực tiếp
chúng ta muốn làm là chúng ta muốn tối
thiểu hóa hàm loss. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
hàm loss mà ra được cái giá trị lost nó
bé ấy thì có nghĩa là dự đoán với thực
tế nó gần nhau. Mà dự đoán với thực tế
mà gần nhau có nghĩa là có nghĩa là làm
sao hả hả các bạn?
Dự đoán thực tế mà gần nhau thì có nghĩa
là sao? Có nghĩa là
>> cái mô hình đang hoạt động tốt ạ.
>> Ờ là mô hình tốt. Đúng rồi. Chính xác
đúng không? Thế nên ấy mọi người hay nói
là tối hóa mô hình hay nói là optimize
model hay là model optimization nhưng mà
thật ra cái chúng ta đang làm gì? Chúng
ta đang minimize lost value đúng không?
Thế các bạn hiểu là gì? Bây giờ khi mà
tôi nói là tôi huấn luyện hay tôi tối ưu
mô hình là thực ra cái thứ mà tôi làm ấy
là tôi đang tối thử hóa cái hàm loss.
Cái loss mới là cái thứ mà chúng ta trực
tiếp chúng ta làm việc cùng đúng không?
Chúng ta không trực tiếp tác động lên mô
hình mà chúng ta trực tiếp tối ưu cái
lót. Tại vì sao? Cái lót muốn tối ưu là
mô hình nó phải tốt lên đúng không? Lots
muốn tố muốn loss muốn tối thiểu là mô
hình nó phải tốt lên đúng không? Thế th
quay lại đây.
Thì bây gi chúng ta nó nói về lây đúng
không? Thì các bạn nhìn này. Thì bây giờ
á, bây giờ ấy thì bây giờ cái loss đúng
không? Loss function là cái thứ dùng để
so sánh giữa dự đoán với thực tế đúng
không? Thì bây giờ cái loss bậc 1 ấy thì
cái sai số nó cứ bình nó bậc 1 thôi. Ông
nào sai số 10 thì là 10, ông nào sai số
1 thì là 1. Nhưng mà với ông min square
ấy thì ông nào sai số 10 nó 100 và ông
nào sai số 1 thì vẫn là 1 đúng không?
Tức là gì? Nó sẽ trừng phạt nghiêm khắc
hơn những cái sai lệch sai, những cái
những cái size lệch lớn. Thế nên là
những cái mô hình mà dùng cái min square
root này ấy nó sẽ có cái xu hướng là gì?
nó sẽ tối thiểu khóa những cái xe lệch
lớn. Tức là cái mô hình chúng ta nó sẽ
ít có những cái xe lệch nó lớn. Thế
nhưng mà cái giá phải trả là gì? Cái giá
phải trả là nó cũng ít có những cái dự
đoán chính xác. Tức là gì? Tức là nó nó
cứ sai nó cứ sai đều đều nó cứ sai đều
đều nhau. Đấy. Tại vì sao? Tại vì là mô
hình nó phải tập trung cái sự chú ý vào
những cái căn nhà có dự đoán size lớn
size số lớn rồi. Nên là những căn nhà mà
có size số bé nó sẽ bị ảnh hưởng đúng
không? Muốn tập trung vào hôm nay thì
phải ch phải chấp nhận là bỏ ông kia.
Được chưa? Thế còn đối với cái mins ý
với cái mins nó sẽ có những cái dự đoán
rất là chính xác nhưng nó cũng sẽ có
những cái dự đoán xch rất là nhiều tại
vì nó bình thẳng đúng không? Sẽ có những
căn mà sai số gần như là không có nhưng
mà sẽ có những căn xi số rất là nhiều.
Đấy. Đây là min suus với cả min square
được chưa?
Dùng cả hai thì nó sẽ bị Dùng cả hai thì
nó sẽ bị nó sẽ bị dùng cả hai nó sẽ
không phải rút một tốt hơn đâu. Các bạn
hiểu này. Khi các bạn dùng cả hai ấy thì
có nghĩa là nó chẳng tập trung vào cái
nào cả đúng không? Nếu mà dùng cả hai có
nghĩa là tôi chẳng tập trung vào cái gì
cả. Tại vì sao? Cái attention của tôi nó
chỉ có từng đấy thôi. Tôi tập trung hơn
vào ông này thì ông kia sẽ bị bỏ đi đúng
không? Về mặt lý thuyết là có thể. Thế
nhưng trong thự tế ta sẽ ít làm như vậy.
Trong thực tế ta sẽ ít làm như vậy. Được
chưa?
Và min square hay là min áp suất ấy đều
có đặc điểm là gì? Càng gần 0 thì càng
tốt đúng không? Càng lớn thì càng tối.
Nó nó không có cận trên, nó chỉ có cận
dưới thôi. Cận dưới là bằng 0 đúng
không? Gần 0 là bé nhất đúng không?
Tùy vào cái mục tiêu các bạn muốn tối
ưu. Các bạn muốn là tránh có những cái
size số lớn thì các bạn dùng min square
nhá. Tránh có những size số lớn thì các
bạn dùng min square. Các bạn muốn là có
những cái size số nó rất là sát thì các
bạn dùng min absolute được cái này thì
mất cái kia. Nếu muốn có những dự án nó
rất là sát thì phải chấp nhận là gì? là
có những lúc dự án nó sai rất là dài,
sai rất là nhiều. Còn muốn là không bao
giờ có những cái dự án nó sai lệch quá
nhiều cả phải chấp nhận là gì? Là không
có ông nào không có ông nào chính xác
cả, không có ông nào xác cả.
Với bài toán reversation thì cái việc mà
eros bằng 0 thì gần như là không thể. E
là không thể đúng không? Các bạn nghĩ mà
xem căn nhà giá 5 tỷ, 5 tỷ chẳng hạn
đúng không? Làm sao mà dự đoán nổi chính
xác 5 tỷ đâ? Nó phải 5 tỷ 300 bao nhiêu
thứ đâ? Làm sao mà chính xác được đúng
không? Kiểu gì nó cũng sai lệch chỉ là
sai lệch ít hay nhiều thôi. Bài toán
reaction thì rất khó có chuyện là er
bằng 0. Rất rất khó.
Rồi có ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
>> Ờ dạy nếu mà sử dụng min square thì nếu
ví dụ cái loss mà nó nằm giá trị nằm
trong khoảng từ 0 tới 1 thì nó nó sẽ
càng sai đúng không? Vì nó bình phương
lên thì nó sẽ nhỏ đi.
>> Ờ vì sao lại trong khoảng t đúng không
nhở? Cận dưới là không đúng rồi nhưng mà
sao lại cận trên làm sao nó có bằng 1
nhỉ?
>> À không ý là nếu mà giá trị nó nằm trong
khoảng đấy thì khi nó bình phương lên
bình thường bình phương lên thì nó sẽ
lớn hơn để mà mình giải quyết được.
>> Đúng đúng đúng chính xác chính xác đúng
xác chính xác đúng rồi. Nếu mà cái size
rồ nó bé hơn 1 đúng bình phương đến con
bé hơn
mình muốn nói rồi nhá. Ví dụ bây gi mình
x mình xng một cái dữ ấn giá nhà đúng
không? Nếu mà mình muốn là cái mô hình
của mình ấy nó không có cái xe lịch nào
nó quá lớn nhá. Nếu mình muốn cái mô
hình của mình nó không có cái xị nào quá
lớn thì mình sẽ dùng min square tại vì
min square root nó sẽ nó sẽ khuấtch đại
những cái sai số lớn lên và khi cái lót
nó lớn rồi thì mình nó sẽ phải tập trung
nó sẽ phải xem là cái cái ông nào là ông
khiến cho lót lớn nó phải tập trung vào
ông đấy. Thế nên là các bạn dùng cái min
square root này thì mình sẽ tập trung
vào những cái căn nhà mà tôi dữ án sai
nhiều. Được chưa? Thì đấy là nếu mà tôi
muốn dùng min square root là khi mà tôi
không muốn có những sai thố nó quá lớn.
Thế còn tôi muốn dùng minus eros là khi
nào? Là khi mà tôi muốn có dự nó rất
chính xác, nó rất là sát với trị thực tế
thì tôi dùng min absolute được chưa?
Nhưng mà được cái này sẽ mất cái kia.
Thế thôi được cái này sẽ mất cái kia
đúng không? Không bao giờ các bạn có thể
được cả hai thứ đúng không?
Đấy là cái sự khác biệt.
Rồi ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Ok.
Thế cả min absolute và min square ấy đều
có
cái min abus nó sẽ có cái giá đ cái giá
phải trả là gì? Là sẽ có những căn nhà
giá nó sai rất nhiều.
sẽ có những căn nhà giá nó sai rất
nhiều. Nó sẽ có những căn giá rất sát và
sẽ có nhân sẽ có những căn giá rất là
sai. Rồi
căn sát thì rất sát và căn sai căn mà
sai lệch nhiều thì sai lệch rất là
nhiều. Đó đấy là cái giá phải trả nhá.
Nào các bạn nhá.
Cả min absolute và cả min square chúng
nó đều có cái đ chung là gì? là càng bé
càng tốt, càng gần không thì càng tốt
đúng không? Và lớn nhất là tồi, lớn nhất
là tồi thế thôi. Thế nhưng mà chúng sẽ
có chung một cái nhược điểm. Chung cái
nhược điểm là gì? Là
chúng ta sẽ nếu chỉ dựa vào cái giá trị
trả về của min absolute và min square
thôi, chúng ta sẽ không biết được xem là
mô hình tốt đến nhường nào. Tại vì sao?
Nếu cho bạn một cái ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ như
thế này. Bây giờ ví dụ đi các bạn. Nhưng
mà các bạn cho mình hỏi nhá. Bây giờ giả
sử mình xây dựng được một cái mô hình dự
đoán giá nhà đúng không? Và cái mô hình
của mình có cái min appos cái sấu trung
bình ấy nó rơi vào khoảng 5 triệu đồng.
Theo các bạn mô hình này là mô hình tốt
hay mô hình tổi?
Recomm
không không mình không phải là phù hợp
với recommendation không recommendation
nó sẽ không dùng cái hàm lot này. Bài
toán recommend nó không dùng cái hàm lot
này.
Không không phải. Ờ cái min square là
tôi nói nào nhỉ? Cái min square là tôi
như mình không biết giấy cái nào khác
nữa. Min square là tôi muốn tránh có
những cái size số nó quá lớn nhá. Tôi
muốn tránh những cái size số quá lớn thì
tôi dùng min square. Tại vì sao? Tì bản
thân min square là nó sẽ khuếch đại
những cái ông xe thố lớn lên và khi
khuếch đại như vậy cái lót nó sẽ lớn.
Lót nó lớn thì mọi người phải tập trung
vào ông đấy. Tập trung vào đấy thì nó sẽ
không còn cái lót lớn nữa. Đấy là cái
min square. Và cái giá phải trả là gì?
Là các bạn nhờ do các bạn đã tránh định
cái xe số lớn rồi. Các bạn phải chấp
nhận là gì? Là cũng sẽ chẳng có cái dự
án nào nó sát cả. Đ nó cứ x đều đều đều
nó không cái nào sát cả. Thế còn mins ấy
thì cái ưu điểm là gì? Nó sẽ có những dự
án cực kỳ sát luôn. Nhưng cái giá phải
trả sẽ có những sai thố nó lớn. Tại vì
sao? Tại vì là tôi không khuếch đại size
đồ đấy lên. Thì bây giờ một căn nhà size
10 nó chỉ tương đương với 10 căn size 1
thôi. Thế nhưng mà min square là một một
căn size 10 nó tương đương với 100 căn
size 1 thì nó sẽ tập trung cái min
square nó sẽ tập trung vào cái size số
lớn hơn là cái min absolute thế thôi.
Được chưa? Mỗi mỗi ông được một cái ông
mà muốn tránh sai số lớn thì cũng sẽ
không có những sai không có những cái
sai số sát. Còn những ông mà muốn là có
những cái dự đoán chính xác thì phải
chấp nhận là có sai số lớn. Thế thôi
nào mô hình mà dự đoán giá nhà sẽ chố
trung bình rơi vào khoảng 5 triệu các
bạn thấy là mô hình tốt hay không các
bạn?
Theo em thì em nghĩ là không đánh giá
được anh.
>> Vì sao?
Ờ thì ví dụ như là căn nhà đó nó khoảng
10 triệu mà mình dự đoán 15 triệu thì
tức là số của mình là 5.
>> Tức là tức là tức là theo theo theo như
em nghĩ là ờ cái việc hàm loss nó lớn
thì nó mô hình của mình nó không tốt là
điều không chắc chắn lắm. Tại vì có thể
là mình dự đoán nhiều căn nhưng mà mình
lại dự đoán size nó nhỏ thì cộng lại nó
ra 5. Nhưng mà có khi là mình dự đoán à
nhiều căn nhưng mà chỉ có một căn mình
dự đoán sai thôi thì căn đó mình dự đoán
sai là 5 thì mình cũng không nên giá
được mô hình tốt hay là xấu.
Ok. Rất cảm ơn câu hỏi. Chào các bạn.
Cái này mình đang muốn hỏi thư tế Việt
Nam tại vì thứ tế Việt Nam thì chắc là
cũng không có căn nào có giá 15 triệu
đúng không các bạn? Giá nhà Việt Nam thì
mình nghĩ là bây giờ nó cũng phải đến
tiền đúng không? Nhà Việt Nam rất là
khó. Căn nào có chỉ có giá mười mấy
triệu đúng không? Theo mình nghĩ là chắc
là bây giờ B ra chắc là cũng phải 1 tỷ
ấy nhở đúng không? Về nhà chắc B có phải
1 tỷ nhở. Mình không biết là có căn nào
1 tỷ không. Bây giờ mình không biết cầm
1 tỷ có mua căn nào không đúng không?
Tức là gì? Với trường hợp dự án giá nhà
đúng không? Thì cái sai lệch 5 triệu nó
rất là nhỏ so với giá của một căn nhà
đúng không? Giá căn nhà nó phải đến hàng
tỷ cơ đúng không? Bây giờ th mình sự
mình không biết là cầm 1 tỷ liệu có mua
nổi nhà ở Việt Nam hay không. Đấy. Thế
nên là thế nên là nếu mà các bạn có một
cái mô hình mà nó xẽ 5 triệu về đồng thì
nó là một mô hình ok. Theo mình nghĩ là
như vậy. Theo mình nó là một mô hình tốt
đúng không? Giá mà 4 tỷ đi dự đoán dự
đoán là 3 t995 triệu thì cũng rất là tốt
rồi đúng không? Thì đấy là một ví dụ
nhá. Tức là trong trường hợp này đúng
không? Cái minos nó rơi vào khoảng 5
triệu. Đấy là một mô hình tốt đúng
không? Thế bây bây giờ trường hợp thứ
hai là gì? Bây gi một cái mô hình dự đán
giá thịt thịt thịt thịt bò đi. Mình muốn
sử một cái mô hình để hàng ngày nó sẽ dự
án giá một cân thịt bò. Thì bây giờ cái
mô hình này ấ mà nó chỉ lệch khoảng vài
chục nghìn thôi đúng không? Giá phân thị
bò bây giờ xây lệch vài chục nghìn thôi
nó cũng là mô hình tồi rồi đúng không?
Tức là gì? Tức là có những trường hợp ấy
sai số cả triệu thì vẫn là mô hình tốt
mà là có những trường hợp sai số nó chỉ
vài chục nghìn thôi nó là mô hình tồi
đúng không? Tức là gì? Tức là nếu mà chỉ
nhìn vào mỗi cái min absolute er cái giá
trị trả về ấy chúng ta sẽ không biết
được là cái giá trị đấy nó là tốt hay
không mà chúng ta phải xem là cái bài
toán đấy hay là chá là gì? Cái thứ mà
chúng ta cần phải dự đoán cái giải giá
trị của nó lớn hay giải hay là cái giải
giá trị của nó bé đúng không? Thì min
absur và min square nó không làm được
điều đấy. Nó không cho chúng ta biết bất
kỳ thông tin gì về cái giải giá trị mà
nó cần phải dự đoán đúng không? Nó không
cho chúng ta biết là gì là giải giá trị
đấy nó lên đến hàng tỷ hay chỉ là vài
trăm nghìn thôi đúng không? Thế đấy là
cái những cái nhược điểm của min absur
và min square er được chưa?
Thế bây giờ để có thể khắc phục được cái
điều này thì bây giờ chúng ta sẽ có một
cái magic được gọi là coefficient of
determination nhá. Sẽ có một cái magic
được gọi là coefficient of
determination.
Cái magic này nó được tính như thế nào?
Cái magic này người ta có một cái tên
gọi khác gọi là a squ. A là chữ R đấy.
Đúng không? Chữ R A đúng không? A square
là R bình phương. Cái magic này nó bằng
1 trừ đi một cái phân số. Được chưa? nó
bằng 1 trừ đi một cái phân số. Cái phân
số này nó sẽ có tử là cái gì? Cái tử của
nó thì nó na l ná như là cái min square
này. Tức là gì? Vẫn là tổng bình phương
của các cái size số thôi, đúng không? Tử
là tổng bình phương của các cái sai số.
Nhưng mà mẫu là cái gì? Mẫu các bạn nhìn
này. Mẫu bây giờ tôi sẽ phải có thêm cái
thứ nữa là gì? Tôi sẽ có cái giá trị
trung bình thực tế của các căn nhà. Được
chưa? Tôi sẽ có dạy trung bình của thực
tế căn nhà là cái đường màu hồng này.
Đường màu hồng hồng cam này. Được chưa?
Thì bây giờ ấy cái đường nét đứt này nó
là cái gì? Đường nét đất này nó là cái
chênh lệch giữa giá trị của từng ngăn
nhà với giá trị trung bình. Được chưa?
Và tôi cũng sẽ tính tổng bình phương
lên. Đây các bạn nhớ không? Cái tử với
mẫu nó khác nhau chưa? Tức là gì? Cái cả
tử cả mẫu thì sẽ đều có giá trị thực tế
tham gia đúng không? Nhưng mà tử thì sẽ
có cả giá trị dự đoán còn mẫu là sẽ có
giá trị trung bình của thực tế đúng
không? Thì biết gậy không? Chính nhờ cái
mẫu này nó đã trung hòa bớt cái tử đúng
không? Nếu các bạn xây dựng mô hình dự
đoán giá nhà thì cả tử cả mẫu nó sẽ đều
đều lớn trung hòa nhau. Còn nếu các bạn
xây dựng mô hình dự đoán giá thịt bò,
thịt lợn, thịt gà thì cả tử cả mẫu nó nó
sẽ đều bé, nó sẽ trung hóa bớt cho nhau
đi đúng không? Đấy. Thế nhờ cái mẫu số
này mà chúng ta đã
phải chúng ta đã scare cái giá trị vào
rồi đúng không? Thì một mô hình tốt là
mô hình nào? Mô hình tốt là mô hình mà
thực tế cả dự đoán nó gần nhau. Mô hình
tốt là mô hình mà cái tử số nó sẽ gần
không đúng không? Mô hình tốt là cái mô
hình mà tử số gần 0. Tử số mà gần 0 thì
cả phân số cũng gần 0 luôn. Mà phân số
gần 0 thì 1 trừ cái phân số đấy sẽ gần 1
đúng không? Tức là gì? Cái a square này
giá trị tốt nhất là bằng 1 đúng không?
Tất nhiên trong thực tế các bạn sẽ không
có mô hình nào bằng 1 hẳn đâu. Nó chỉ
gần 1 thôi đúng không? Càng gần 1 thì
càng tốt. Còn mô hình tồi là mô hình
nào? Mô hình tồi là cái mô hình mà dự án
vi phết từ đấy nó sẽ cách xa nhau. Tức
là khi mà tử số nó lớn đ tử với mẫu nó
mà lớn xem nhau thì phân số nó sẽ gần 1.
Thì mô hình tồi là mô hình mà cái a
square nó sẽ gần với 0. có thể 1 trừ đi
phân số mà thậm chí có những cái mô hình
mà cái a square còn dưới cả 0 nữa. Tại
vì sao? Tại vì cái tử nó lớn quá. Cái mô
hình mà nó nó rất là tồi. Cái tử nó lớn
thì thậm chí cái phân số này nó lớn hơn
nó lớn hơn 1 đúng không? Tử lớn hơn mẫu
mà. Đấy mà khi phân số lớn hơn 1 thì 1
trừ nó còn nó nó còn nhỏ hơn 0. Tức là
sẽ có những mô hình nó rất là tồi đ mô
hình mà cái a square nó còn bé hơn cả 0
cơ. Đấy thì đấy là về cái magic
coefficient of determination hay gọi là
a square. Đây một magric vô cùng phổ
biến và đừng dụng rất là rộng rãi để
đánh giá cái mô hình này cho bài toán
request nhá. Bên cạnh cái magic
phổ thông như là min absur với cả min
square thì chúng ta có coefficient of
determinations.
Rồi
các bạn nhìn mình quố mất ch các bạn là
gì? Cái màu xanh này là giá trị thực tế
đúng không? Màu đỏ là dự đoán. Ví dụ
chúng ta dự đoán là cái giá của nhà nó
sẽ nằm trong cái đường như này đúng
không? Thì màu đỏ dự đoán là trong cái
đường như này đúng không? Đây màu xanh
là thực tế, màu đỏ là dự đoán đúng
không? Đây cũng thế xanh là thực tế, đỏ
là dự đoán.
Anh ơi.
>> Ừ. À
>> cái r bình phương á anh Ừ.
>> Ở trên cái phần tử của nó là mình là
dùng square arrow.
>> Đúng rồi.
>> Còn bên dưới mình có bình phương đâ
không anh? Cái
>> có bên vuông nghĩa là bình phương đấy.
Đây
>> một cái nét này thì là bậc 1 đúng không?
Này thì là bình phương. Đấy bình phương
này bình phương cả tử cả mẫu
nhá.
Rồi nào có bạn nào câu hỏi gì về các cái
các cái m này nữa không?
Đây là ba máy mắt vô cùng phổ biến cho
bài toán regression nhá.
Nào các bạn nhìn kỹ nào. Có ai có thắc
mắc gì nữa không?
Ngoài ra th nó còn nó còn một vài cái
nữa. Ví dụ chúng ta còn có một cái là
root min square root. Tức là gì? Tính ra
cái min square rồi đóng căn bậc hai vào
thì nó thành root min square root. Thế
nhưng mà nó cũng từ đây mà ra thôi.
Vì sao lại hiệu quả? Tại vì nó giúp
chúng ta đánh giá được xem là nó nó đưa
cả cái giải giá trị mà mình cần phải
đoán vào trong đúng không? Ví dụ đây như
mình vừa nói rồi. Các bạn nhìn vào cái
các bạn nhìn vào cái mins hoặc là min
square root ấy, các bạn không biết là mô
hình tốt hay tồi. Tại vì sao? Các bạn
không biết cái giải giá trị của cái thứ
mà các bạn cần phải dự đoán đúng không?
Ví dụ với mô hình dự giá nhà đi. Min
suus mà 5 triệu vẫn là mô hình tốt đúng
không? Nhưng mà với mô hình dự án giá
thịt bò thì minus nó chỉ vài trăm ngìn
vài chục nghìn thôi nó là mô hình tồi
rồi đúng không? Thế bây giờ các bạn nhìn
vào mỗi nó làm sao các bạn biết tốt hay
tồi được đúng không? Các bạn mà không
biết bài toán các bạn chỉ nhìn vào mỗi
matric thôi các bạn sẽ các bạn nhìn vào
mỗi cái er thôi các bạn sẽ không biết
đúng không? Nhưng mà với đây với cái
cofficient này đúng không các bạn không
cần không cần biết bài toán luôn các bạn
không cần biết bài toán là đang dự án
giá nhà hay giá thịt bò các bạn chuyển
nhìn vào giá trị các bạn đã biết rồi.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì cái mẫu số nó đã
trung hòa cho cái tử số rồi đúng không?
Tử số mà giải trị nó lớn thì mẫu số
thì mẫu số nó nó cũng lớn theo mà tử số
nó bé thì mẫu số nó cũng bé theo. Vì sao
lại phải lấy -1? Tại vì 1 trừ đi tại vì
người ta muốn là cái magic này ấ nó càng
lớn thì càng tốt đúng không? Người ta
muốn cái magic này nó càng lớn thì càng
tốt nên người ta lấy 1 trừ đi thôi.
>> Vậy thì trong thực tế thì mình chỉ áp
dụng duy nhất một cái là COD thôi đúng
không?
Ờ thường ta sẽ áp dụng nhiều tại vì này
cái
coefficient determination này nó có cái
ưu điểm là đánh giá tốt. Thế nhưng mà
cái nhược điểm nó lại ít trực quan. Nó
ít trực quan. Ví dụ cái mins nhá. Nhìn
biết tôi biết à trung bình là dự án sai
số 5 triệu. Thế còn khi mà mình đã đưa
về mình đã đưa về đây thôi ấy thì tôi
chỉ biết là gì? Gần một tốt thôi nhưng
mà tôi tôi sẽ không hình dung được là
thế trung bình mỗi căn tôi mỗi mỗi cái
đối tượng tôi dự đoán sai số bao nhiêu.
Thế tức là ông này thì nó sẽ đo đảo
chính xác hơn nhưng mà hai ông này nó
lại trực quan hơn. trực quan
>> có nghĩa là mình ở trong dự thế mình sẽ
áp dụng kết hợp nhiều cái nhau. Ví dụ
như là đầu tiên mình sẽ dùng một cái MAE
[hắng giọng] hoặc là MSE để mình nhìn ra
được cái số thực tế. Sau đó mình sẽ tiếp
tục mình áp dụng một cái COD để mình tìm
ra được à cái số thực tế nào là là rõ
nhất là là có có như kiểu là có có
>> ấy nhất ấyọi là đúng nhất ấy. Dạ vâng.
Đúng rồi. Đúng rồi. Trong tế mình sẽ
không bắt buộc là mình chỉ dùng một cái
mình có thể dùng nhiều cái đúng không?
đánh giá của một người mình có thể dùng
nhiều thước nhiều thức đo nhiều phương
pháp tính mà không
>> đúng rồi mình phải kết hợp nhiều cái để
mình ra được cái số đúng với cái bài
toán mình đề ra đúng không ạ
>> dạ dạ chính xác
ờ các bạn chú ý này nhá khi mà các bạn
tức là như này ba ông này ấy ba cái thứ
này ấy vừa dùng làm hàm hất m được vừa
dùng làm magic được
nhá các bạn nhìn này nhá cả ba cái này
ấy vừa dùng làm hàm mắt m được vừa dùng
làm matrix được thế nhưng khi mà chúng
ta ờ
khi mà chúng ta khi mà chúng ta dùng là
mất mát ấy chúng ta phải chọn một trong
một trong Đúng rồi cái cái cái a square
người ta ít khi người ta dùng mất mát
hơn nhưng mà cũng có thể dùng nhưng mà
người ta ít khi người ta dùng hơn các
bạn chú ý này nhá khi mà muốn dùng làm
hàm mất mát ấy các bạn phải chọn một
trong mấy ôm này không được dùng tất cả
đúng không khi dùng làm hàm á hoặc là
mins hoặc là min square Cái question thì
người ta sẽ người ta sẽ ít khi người ta
dùng hơn. Ít khi người ta dùng hơn đúng
không? Người ta vẫn dùng nhưng mà ít khi
dùng hơn. Thế còn khi mà các bạn dùng để
đánh giá tức là khi mà dùng để làm magic
ý thì các bạn dùng cả ba cái thoải mái.
Dùng nhiều cái cùng lúc cũng được không
vấn đề gì. Nhưng khi làm khi mà dùng làm
h làm mất mát ấ chỉ dùng một trong mạch
cái này thôi. Tại vì sao? Phải có một
chúng ta phải có một cái đối tượng để
chúng ta tối ưu chứ. Chúng ta tối ưu
theo bậc một hay là bậc hai hay là theo
cái gì đúng không? Đấy khi mà làm hàm
mất mát dùng một thôi. Còn khi mà tôi
huấn luyện xong hết rồi tôi đánh giá
magic cuối cùng tôi dùng hàng mất mát
cũng tôi dùng tôi dùng minus cũng được
dùng min square cũng được hay là tôi
dùng cái a square cũng được nhá.
>> À có nghĩa là trong quá trình training
và valid
một cái thôi. Còn sau đó khi kết thúc
câu chuyện thì mình mới được áp dụng
nhiều cái để mình đánh giá.
>> Đúng rồi. Chính xác chính xác. Giống như
kiểu là bây giờ mình tốt nghiệp t ví dụ
là lúc mà ngày xưa mình đi học ấy đúng
không? Khi mình thi học kỳ là chỉ có cô
giáo chấm bài thôi. Có lúc mình ra
trường rồi thì mình có thể làm bài thi
tố hiệu chủ phổ thông rồi mình ra ngoài
mình chỗ này chỗ kia mình làm những cái
bài test riêng nữa. Tức là sẽ có nhiều
chỗ người ta đ đánh đánh giá mình mỗi
chỗ lại đánh giá theo một cái hệ khác
nhau kiểu kiểu như vậy.
>> Dạ. Ok.
>> Rồi. Ok.
Có bắt nào có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Đây các bạn nhớ nhá. Đây là những cái
thứ dành cho bài toán re
thứ dành cho bài toán re. Được chưa?
Còn với bài toán classification thì sao?
Bài toán classification ấy thì gần như
là chỉ có một cái hàm loss duy nhất
người ta dùng thôi. Đó là cross opy loss
nhá. Đây gần như là hàm loss độc tôn cho
bài toán classification rồi đúng không?
Trong bài toán các bạn còn có là min
absolute này, min square này, root min
square và đôi khi người ta cũng dùng
cảion nữa. Thế nhưng mà đối với bài toán
classification thì gần như là người ta
chỉ dùng mỗi lôi. Cái máy tính nào các
bạn nhìn nhá. Thế bây giờ giả sử này bây
giờ mình đang nước
các bạn nhìn nhá. Giả sử bây giờ mình
đang có một bài toán phân loại, bài toán
classification có bốn class đi là chó,
mèo, ờ con kiến cả con cáo đúng không?
Phân tức là bây giờ là một cái ảnh và mô
hình nó phải đưa dự xem là cái ảnh này
nó thuộc về con chó, con mèo, con kiến
hay là con con cáo đúng không?
Thế bây gi các bạn tưởng tượng nhá, hãy
tưởng tượng như là cái mô hình machining
của mình đi đúng không? Nó sẽ dự nó cái
nào là nó sẽ gán số điểm cho từng class.
Ví dụ cái mô hình của mình là một cái m
hình X là gì đấy đúng không? Cái m hình
X đấy mình không biết đúng không? Nhưng
mà tóm lại là với cái ảnh đổ vào bàn ảnh
con chó này nó sẽ gán số điểm cho cái
class. Con chó là 4,8 điểm, con mèo là
2,4 điểm, con kiến là -4,1 [hắng giọng]
điểm và con cáo là 1,1 điểm. Được chưa?
nó gá điểm như vậy thì tất nhiên là sau
khi có cái điểm này rồi ấy tôi có thể
tôi dễ dàng tôi chỉ ra là mô hình dự đó
là con nào bằng cách gì tôi xem là ông
nào là ông lớn nhất thôi đúng không 4,8
là số lớn nhất thì có nghĩa là gì mô
hình này nó dự đoán là cái ảnh này nó là
con chó đúng không tôi chỉ nhìn vào cái
số điểm thô của mô hình nó nó đưa ra
thôi là tôi biết luôn là cái gì nó là
cái gì rồi. Thế nhưng nếu tôi muốn tính
loss thì nó sẽ không đơn giản như vậy.
Tại vì sao?
Thì các bạn hiểu này, với bài toán phân
loại ấy, cái lost của tôi ấy, tôi sẽ
không cái thứ tôi thứ thứ mà tôi cần ấy
không phải chỉ là đánh giá xem dưỡng
đúng hay là sai mà tôi phải đánh giá xem
là nếu đúng thì đúng đến mức nào và nếu
sai thì sai đến mức nào đúng không?
Cái mà tôi muốn dự đoán ấy không phải là
cái mô hình nó có dự đoán đúng là con
chó hay không mà tôi muốn dự đoán là mà
tôi muốn đánh giá là gì? Nếu nó dự đoán
đúng là con chó thì nó dự đoán tốt đến
mức nào? Còn nếu nó dự án sai dự án tồi
đến mức nào? Thì bây giờ làm sao để tôi
có thể đánh giá được cái điều đấy? Thì
bây giờ bản là một cái việc là gì? Là
bây giờ ấy những cái dự đoán ban đầu của
cái mô hình này 4,8 2,4 - 4,1 1,1 này ấy
tôi phải cho nó đi qua một cái hàm gọi
là hàm soft max nhá. Cái hàm này gọi là
hàm soft max. Cái hàm này nó bằng cái
gì? Cái hàm soft max tính cho từng phần
tử một nó bằng e mũ i. E mũ yy đúng
không? Iy là I1, I2, I32, I4 này đúng
không? Chia cho tổng của tất cả những E
này được không? Tức là gì? Với cái ông
đầu tiên nó sẽ bằng gì? Nó bằng e mũ 4,8
chia cho e mũ 4,8 cộng e mũ 2,4 + e mũ
tr- 4,1 + e mũ 1,1 đúng không? Nó ra
được cái số 0,9. Mấy ông kia thì cũng đế
mấy ông Việt thì cũng tương tự như thế
đúng không? Các cái phân số này nó chỉ
khác nhau ở cái tử số thôi còn mẫu số
giống y hiệt nhau đúng không? Ông đầu
cái tử là e mũ 4,8 ông 2 là e mũ 2,4.
Thế thôi nó kết quả như này. Thế các bạn
nhìn này. Input mà ông nào to ấy thì
output ông đấy vẫn to đúng không? Input
ông nào nhỏ thì output nó vẫn nhỏ đúng
không? Thế nhưng mà cái output này nó sẽ
có một cái đặc điểm là gì? là tổng của
chúng sẽ bằng 1 và các cái giá trị nó sẽ
luôn nằm trong khoảng từ 0 đến 1 đúng
không? Cái lúc ban đầu này cái
prediction này ấ các cái giá trị nó có
thể nằm từ âm vô cùng đến dương vô cùng
đúng không? Nó không có cái giới hạn gì
nhưng mà khi các bạn cho nó qua cái hàm
sắc này rồi ấy thì cái giới hạn là gì?
Là kết quả nó sẽ chỉ là khoảng từ 0 cho
đến 1 mà thôi. Đấy từ 0 đến 1 đâu. Mỗi
ông là từ 0 cho đến 1 đúng không? Và
tổng đúng bằng 1 luôn. Và do đó ấ chúng
ta có thể chúng ta giải thích đây chính
là cái mức độ confident, mức độ tin
tưởng của mô hình và từng dự đoán. Tức
là gì? Cái mô hình mình nó dự đoán là
gì? Cái ảnh này 90% con chó.
8% là con mèo, 0% là con kiến và 2% là
con cáo. Đúng không? Sau đó thì tôi rõ
ràng nếu đây thực sự là con chó thì cái
số điểm 0,9 này rất là tốt đúng không?
Thế nhưng mà nếu mà đây mà con mèo thì
cái số điểm này nó lại không tốt. Tức là
gì? Mô tôi phải có một cái hàm lót nào
để tôi làm sao tôi sẽ nếu mà cái số điểm
đúng của cái ln ấy thì cái điện ló nó sẽ
bé và ngược lại đúng không? Thì bây giờ
tô tức là gì? Tức là nếu đây là ảnh con
chó, tôi muốn cái số này nó càng cao thì
càng tốt. Còn nếu đây không phải ảnh con
chó thì tôi muốn là cái số này nó sẽ
càng bé càng tốt. Đúng không? Ví dụ đây
là ảnh con chó, tôi muốn là cái số điểm
của con chó nó càng cao càng tốt này.
Còn ba con kia càng bé càng tốt đúng
không? Còn nếu đây không ảnh con chó đây
ảnh con mèo tôi sẽ muốn là cái chỗ này
nó cao còn ba con kia nó thấp đúng
không? Thế bây giờ tôi sao tôi đánh giá
ký điều đấy? Tôi sẽ dùng cái hàm là
cross entropy. Cross entropy là gì? Các
bạn nhìn trong trường hợp đấy nó bằng
gì? Nó bằng trừ của tổng sigma y chạy từ
1 cho đến 4. Bốn là số độ class này nó
bằng gì? Nó bằng cái nhãn cái label đấy
nhân với cái log của cái xác suất này.
Xác suất property này lúc này log cơ số
2 đúng không? Tức là gì? Cái nhãn này là
gì? Cái label i label 1 là bằng 1 này.
Label 2 bằng 0, label 3 bằng 0, label 4
= 0. Tức là nó sẽ bằng cái gì? Nó bằng
trừ đi đúng không? Nó bằng trừ này. Trừ
ở ngoài này. Ở bên trong là tổng của cái
gì? Tổng của 1 nhân với logarit câ số 2
của 0,9 cộng 0 nhân với logarit cơ số 2
của 0,08 cộng với 0 nhân với logarit cơ
số 2 của 0 cộng với 0 nhân với logarit c
số 2 của 0,02 đúng không? Tất nhiên là
mấy cái ông nhân với 0 thì nó bằng 0 hết
rồi đúng không? Thế nhưng mà kết quả
cuối cùng là nó sẽ là như thế này đúng
không? Công thức tổng quát đây đúng
không? Đây các bạn nhìn cái công thức ở
dưới này. Đấy quả tính dưới này. Đấy thì
đây chính là cái kết quả của cross
entropy loss khi chúng ta áp dụng vào
cho cái ví dụ này. Được chưa?
Vì sao phải có cái dấu phải có cái dấu
trừ? Tại vì logarit câu số 2 của những
số bé hơn 1 nó sẽ là số âm đúng không?
Lót thì không thể âm được đặt số trừ ra
ngoài. Được chưa?
Và cái lót này tất nhiên nó sẽ càng bé
càng tốt, càng lớn càng tồi. Bé nhất thì
là bằng 0. Bé nhất thì là bằng 0.
Khi nào cái lót này nó bằng 0? Khi mà
cái xác suất cho cái lót đúng nó đúng
bằng 100% luôn. Nếu xác suất cho cái lót
đúng đúng 100% luôn thì cái lót này nó
sẽ bằng 0 ngay.
Rồi có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì về cái hàm
lot này không? Ô cái nhãn 100 vừa rồi là
mình vừa tựa đưa vào hay là mình tính
như nào nhở? nhãn này là phải có từ ban
đầu nó rượu có đánh nhãn mà đây là
>> đây là bài toán classification là bài là
bài toán dùng rượu có đánh nhãn mình có
cái nhãn này.
>> Nếu mà có trường hợp nào mà không đánh
nhãn 1 không nhá thì nó thành bài toán
un learning rồi. Nếu mà không có nhãn
thì nó không phải là bài toán phân loại
nữa. Đây là
>> ý mình có đánh nhãn. Có đánh nhãn nhưng
mà đánh nhãn theo kiểu định dạng khác
chẳng hạn. Ví dụ a axxx
hoặc là x oo chẳng hạn thì có được
không? Thì có tính áp dụng được cái hàm
los này nữa không? Đây là mình đang mình
đang áp cái nhãn theo kiểu số thực số
nguyên là 1+ 0 thì mình tính mới được
cái công thức này.
>> Vâng.
>> Còn nếu mà ông nào ông cho là AB BB
chẳng hạn
>> ABB nhưng mà ABB nó là cái gì ạ?
>> Theo kiểu dạng chữ
mình không dùng 1 ở đây chẳng hạn
mà mình dùng XO oôo nhưng mà XO nó có ý
nghĩa gì nhưng mà nóại có một cái ý ý
nghĩa gì đấy chứ đúng không ạ?
Thế thì mình mới hỏi là nó cái ý nghĩa
đấy nó phụ thuộc vào người đánh nhãn.
Người người ta đánh nhãn là à ờ X là sẽ
chính là con chó này chẳng hạn hoặc là X
sẽ là con mèo hoặc X sẽ là con kiến.
>> Vâng.
>> Hoặc là nếu hoặc là Y thì sẽ không phải.
>> Nhưng mà nhưng mà sao sao họ phải làm
hội được khổ đúng b đấy nhở? Nó nó chỉ
là cho mèo thôi.
>> Không mình không mình không hỏi khổ hay
không. Mình nếu mà trong trường hợp giả
sử người ta đánh đánh như thế có trường
hợp nào người ta đánh cái kiểu đấy
>> là em cũng chưa gặp ai tại vì nó nó nó
phức tạp quá ấy em cũng chưa thấy ai
đánh như thế cả
>> à
>> t mà thật ra nếu họ đánh như thế mình
mình mình convert được mà nếu mà quy ước
là x mình convert ra cái này xuống này
đây là kiểu one hot dễ mà convert được
thôi đúng không tức là có thể họ sẽ
không bịnh nhẵn này họ sẽ đánh nhãn là
đây là chó là dog dog thì sẽ là 100 mèo
là 0100 như vậy thôi convert dễ thôi mà
>> ừ tại vì trong trường hợp vừa rồi là Có
một bài toán có một đứa trẻ là tam giác
hình vuông, tam giác hình tròn chẳng hạn
thì mình cũng nên đánh là 1 này đúng
không ạ? Kể cả họ có ghi chữ là tròn thì
mình sẽ quý là gì? Tròn là 100, vuông là
>> và tam giác là 001. Rất là dễ luôn. Mình
chỉ convert từ từ cái ngôn ngữ con người
cho thành cái vecơ thôi là là được rồi.
>> Ừ.
>> Có nghĩa là cuối cùng mình vẫn phải nên
là convert lại thành một cái vecơ để
mình áp dụng công thức.
>> Thật ra thì khi chúng ta dùng thư viện
ấy chúng ta không phải không cần phải
convert, chúng ta chỉ đảm bảo gì? là cái
label ấy nó có hữ hạn giá trị khác nhau
thôi. Ví dụ ở đây có bốn label là doc,
cat, an với cả for này. Thì khi mà đưa
vào thư viện ấy nó sẽ tự động nó sẽ phân
lại ra thành bốn cái nhóm như này. Thế
mình không cần phải mình không cần phải
tự mình chuyển ra thành số.
>> À ok.
>> Thật ra thì dù cái dạng gì cũng thế
thôi. Chúng ta là con người chúng ta
thừa sức chúng ta có thể convert được về
cái dạng này mà gì có thể convert được.
Ok. Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Ờ cái phần label mà ra kết quả là do là
1 kia là nó dựa vào cái đánh giá của
model đúng không ạ?
>> Label là cái thứ mà phải có người ta
đánh nhãn sẵn. Label không bao giờ dựa
vào đánh nhãn của mô hình. Đánh nhá.
>> Đấy là kết quả mình test lại mô hình
đúng không ạ?
>> Cái dự đoán mô hình là cái phần
prediction này. Dự đán mô hình là phần
prediction này. Còn label là có người ta
cầm bút người ta đánh vào đấy.
>> Dạ vâng ạ. Cảm ơn ạ.
Prediction nó từ đâu ra thầy?
>> Dạ sao ạ?
>> Cái cái prediction
>> tức là mấy cái số này á là nó từ đâu ra?
>> Cái prion cái prediction 4,8 2,4 ạ. Đây
là một cái ví dụ. Đây là một cái ví dụ
để cho mọi người có thể hình dung được
là đấy mô hình dự nó sẽ trông như thế
này.
>> Ấy ấy là ấy em là cái tức là mình có một
cái model và nó sẽ trong đó nó đã được
setup hay là config gì đó để nó
>> mình đã có một cái mô hình đúng không?
Mình có một cái mô hình mô hình mình
mình coi như mình đang huấn luyện nó đi
đúng không? Và khi mình đưa cái phút đ
vào này nó sẽ ra cái đầu ra như nó như
thế này đúng không? Đây là một cái ví dụ
thôi nó có thể là 4,8 4,7 4,6 4,5 4 phẩy
mấy 2 phẩy mấy thoải mái đúng không? Đây
chỉ là một cái ví dụ là như thế này.
>> À
>> đây là một cái ví dụ
>> tức là một mô hình nó sẽ đưa ra nhiều
prediction
và mình có cái shop qua cái cái method
shop để mình ra cái probability
một
>> sau đó mình tính [hắng giọng] cái lost
một mô hình với một cái input đầu vào nó
sẽ ra một cái dự đoán ví dụ như thế này.
Ví dụ đây bài toán có bốn class ví dụ
đây là cái dự án của mô hình
>> nó có thể là 4,8 4,7 4,6 whatever. Nhưng
mà cái dự án này thì đây là cái dự án
thô. Thì thật ra chúng ta nhìn vào dự
đoán thô này chúng ta cũng phải biết là
mô hình dự đoán là class nào rồi. Tại vì
là ông nào lớn thì là ông đấy là chọn
thôi. Thế nhưng mà mình muốn tính ra cái
lot thì mình sẽ phải cho qua cái max để
có thể giải thích được cái kiểu xác suất
như này. Sau đó từ cái xác suất này
chúng ta mới so sánh, chúng ta mới tương
tác với cái label để ra được cái l cù
như thế này.
>> Anh ơi giả sử là khi mình chạy cái hàm
này ấ mà mình chưa chạy hàm loss ấ thì
nó có trả ra prediction cho mình gồm hai
cột như này không anh?
>> Lost là sẽ phải xảy ra sau prediction.
Vâng. Tức là nếu mà mình không chạy hàm
loss ấy mà mình muốn xem mỗi cái
prediction thôi.
>> Được chưa? Được chưa? Được chứ? Được
chứ.
>> Thì nó sẽ trả cho mình hai cột như này
đúng không anh?
>> Thì thì ra cái gì?
>> Thì nó sẽ trải cho mình hai cột giá trị
như thế này đúng không anh?
>> Hai cột là hai cột nào nhở? Cái cái cái
cái
>> I48 này.
>> I3 I4 với cả cái cột 4.8.
>> Ừ. Đây là cái dã thuộ của mô hình mà các
bạn thể nhá. Lost là cái bài trước của
cô giáo. Bài chữa của cô giáo nó chỉ đến
khi nào? Khi mà học sinh làm bài rồi thì
bây giờ các bạn không nhìn vào bài chữ
đó, các bạn nhìn vào bài làm của học
sinh thì đây chính là cái prediction
này. Prediction nó chính là bài làm của
học sinh nó đúng không? Xong là còn khi
mà mình chạy hàm los thì đây chính là
quá trình nó chạy hàm để so sánh với cả
cái giá trị label thực tế của nó đúng
không anh?
>> Đúng rồi, đúng rồi. Chính xác, chính
xác.
>> Trong cái label này này anh này thì các
cái số nó đánh giá nó đánh giá phân loại
theo thành số này để cho cái hàm loss
này nó hiểu và tính toán thì các cái giá
trị này nó có hữu hạn số lượng giá trị
không hay là nó chỉ được hai giá trị. số
thôi anh nhỉ? Kiểu 10 hoặc hai tức là nó
chỉ được có hai giá trị hay là nó nhiều
giá trị được
>> hai giá trị là cái chỗ nào mình nói đến
chỗ label hay là chỗ nào
>> chỗ label chỗ label label 100 của mấy đ
>> ngoài ngoài 0 với 1 nó cũng chẳng thể có
giá trị nào khác được làm gì có giá trị
nào khác bây giờ
cũng chả có giá trị nào khác cả đúng
không các bạn có bốn con hay là các bạn
có 40 con hay có 400 con thì nó cũng chỉ
có 1 với 0 thôi
>> à nó tức là cái tức là khi anh cho mô
hình là cái label nó tự cái mô hình này
nó sẽ tự đánh nhãn cho cái bọn này là 1
chỉ 2 Label không có không có mồi nào
đánh nhãn label cả. Phải có con người
người ta ngồi người ta đánh nhãn. Nhãn
là phải có con người. Vâng.
>> Nhãn là phải có con người.
>> Và cái nhãn này là con người đánh giá
cũng chúng đúng. Nhãn này là con người
nhìn bằng mắt thường, nhìn bằng mắt của
mình và đánh nó vào.
>> Vâng. Đúng rồi.
>> Dù dù có bao nhiêu giá trị để phân loại
chăng nữa thì khi con người đánh giá và
đánh label trong nó thì cũng chỉ có 1
trong cái bài toán này thôi.
>> Đúng rồi. Mà thật ra ấy sẽ chẳng qua
ngồi ta ghi không đâu. Ngườ ta chỉ ghi
là do với k thôi. Đây chẳng qua mình
đang convert cho các bạn cho các bạn
hình dung được là cái lót này nó tính
như nào đúng không?
>> Tại vì người ta sẽ luôn dùng nhé kiểu
onh tức là gì?
>> Đúng cái ông đấy thì bằng 1 nhưng ông
khác bằng 0. Đấy nên là mình có 4 hay là
40 400 nó cũng chỉ có 1 với 0 thôi. Nó
không thể có cái giá trị khác được.
>> Vâng.
>> Đấy
>> vâng vâng em cảm ơn ạ.
>> Ừ.
Sao hàm los nó có cái negative vậy thầy?
>> Dạ.
>> Sao nó có cái dấu trừ trên hàm loss vậy
thầy?
>> Tại vì nếu không có trừ nó sẽ bị âm.
Không có trừ nó sẽ bị âm.
>> Ồ log của số nhỏ hơn 1 không thầy?
>> Đúng rồi. Log số nhỏ hơn 1 nó sẽ bị âm.
Và vì có cái dấu trừ này thì nó mới đảm
bảo là lost càng bé càng tốt. Còn nếu mà
không có dấu trừ ấy thì nó nó sẽ càng
lớn càng tốt.
Đ nhở. Làm sao để biết được mô hình của
mình đã tốt ngang và tốt hơn mô hình
người khác ạ. Mình sẽ dành bằng gì? Mình
sẽ đánh bằng magic.
Làm sao để biết là bạn A tốt tôi tốt hơn
bạn B tất cả đi thi thốc hiệu chu phổ
thông ông vào điểm cao thì đấy tốt hơn
đúng không? Dựa vào matric đúng không?
Dựa vào cái bài thi tốt nghiệp chu phổ
thông ấy là cái bài test ấy đúng không?
Mô hình A mà có cái magic tốt hơn mô
hình B thì đây là mô hình tốt hơn rồi
đúng không? Con người như nào máy y
chang như thế mà đúng không? Có người
làm máy y trang như thế
đây chỉ là mô hình mô hình đ để ra được
thì phải qu một netw không đây cũng đây
cũng không phải new network new network
nó cũng dùng này nhưng mà đây đây đây nó
đây mình mình mình chưa có đạo độc gì
new network ở ở đây cả đây chỉ là một
cái mô hình của mình nó dự đoán như vậy
thôi đúng không đây dùng cho cả new
network và cả các mô hình ming truyền
thống
đúng rồi đây chỉ kết quả thôi mình mình
ghi rõ mà prediction là dự đoán thôi các
bạn ạ prediction là dự đoán đúng không
ấy chúng ta chưa đề cập đến một mô hình
cụ thể nào đúng không chúng ta coi như
là gì? Cái mô hình của mình nó đưa dự
đoán như này đúng không? Và đây mình
mình không nói về một cái mô hình nào
cả, mình chỉ nói về cái dự đoán của mô
hình thôi đúng không? Hãy coi như là có
một cái mô hình đúng không? Nó đưa ra
một cái dự án nó như thế này. Được chưa?
Nó ra một cái số điểm nó như thế này.
Thế thôi đúng không? Còn chúng ta không
nói một cái mô hình cụ thể nào cả. Đúng
là thường người ta hay minh họa thuần
này thông qua Newal Network nhưng mà nó
không phải chỉ dành cho new network, nó
dành cho các cái thuật toán chung chung
trong classification.
Rồi có ai có câu hỏi gì nữa không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Nhớ nhá. Label là do con người, còn
prediction là do mô hình. Prediction là
bài làm của các bạn còn label là cái
bent đáp án cô có sẵn. Được chưa? Label
thì không có chuyện mình dự đoán ra
label đâu nhá.
Các bạn cho mình hỏi này, ở đây người ta
đã chuẩn hóa các cái giá trị dự đoán của
mô hình thông qua cái hàm só max nhưng
mà cái hàm sắc này nhìn nó hơi phức tạp
nhỉ? Sao lại cần phải e mũ là gì nhở?
Sao không không chỉ đơn giản là gì là tử
số là I1, mẫu số là tổng của I1, I2, I3,
I4 cho nhanh đúng không? Sao lại cần
phải là e mũ I1 cho phức tạp đi đúng
không? Nếu mà cái ông đầu tiên là I1
chia cho tổng bốn cái y, ông thứ hai là
I2 chia tổng 4 Y, ông này là I3, ông này
là I4 chẳng hạn, nó dễ hơn nhiều đúng
không? Sao lại phải dùng hàm só max này?
Tuy nhiên lại phải có hàm e làm gì cho
nó khổ ra.
để tránh kết quả âm ạ.
>> À đúng rồi, tránh kết quả âm. Để tránh
kết quả âm không phải khuyếch đại khuyết
đủng gì cả. Tránh kết quả âm đúng không?
Để tránh kết quả bị âm. Nếu chúng ta
dùng cái hàm như mình vừa mới bịa ra ấy,
nó sẽ có kết quả nó âm ngay đúng không?
Xác suất thì làm sao mà âm được đúng
không? Xác suất thì không thể âm được. Đ
nhá. Đây là cái hàm loss được dùng cực
kỳ cực kỳ phổ biến trong
bài toán classification.
Ngoài ra nó sẽ có một vài hàm lót nữa nó
là phiên bản mở rộng, phiên bản modify
một chút của cái hàm hàm của cái hàm lót
này. Nó sẽ một vài phiên bản nó mở rộng
một chút. Thế nhưng mà nhìn chung là đều
dựa vào cái tinh thần của hlot ngay đúng
không? Các bạn thấy đặc điểm không? Nó
không chỉ đánh giá là dự án đúng hay
sai, nó dự đoán là đúng đến mức nào, sai
mức nào chứ không phải là bước ẩn này nó
là dự án đúng thì nó được 10 điểm, sai
nó được điểm không phải như vậy. Nó xem
là đúng đến mức nào và sai đến mức nào
đúng không? Điều đây đều rất là quan
trọng trong hình tối ưu của mình.
Tại vì sao? Tại vì trong quá trình mà
các bạn à đi học ấy cái việc đánh giá
đúng không? Cô không thể cô chấm bài, cô
chỉ chấm là đúng với sai được mà phải
xem đúng không? Có thể một bài các bạn
đúng đến 50% nó phải khác. Bài đúng 70%
nó phải khác chứ đúng không? Đây nó cũng
như vậy đúng không? Đấy và nhớ nhá.
Cross cross lot bé nhất là bằng 0. Càng
hơn 0 thì càng tốt, càng to thì càng tồi
nhá.
Rồi, đấy là về các cái hàm mất mát. Thế
còn đối với Magric ấy thì
cái này thì chắc là ờ
rồi.
Đấy là về nó lý thuyết buổi hôm nay. Bây
giờ mình sẽ nói qua một chút về bài tập
bài tập về nhà các bạn nhá. Bài tập về
nhà thì mình sẽ cho các bạn tám bài. Các
bạn có hai option. Một là
các bạn chờ tí tĩa buổi này xong mình sẽ
đế tí mình sẽ ngồi mình up bài tập về
nhà luôn cho các bạn nhá. Bài tập nhà
trông sẽ như này. Mình nói qua một tí
này. Nói qua một tí nhá. Ờ my class nhá.
Các bạn có hai option. Một là làm bảy
bài đầu và hai là các bạn làm đúng cái
bài cuối thôi.
Đây
các bạn chờ tí mình download về đã. Mình
lỡ tay mình xóa mất nên là nó chưa có.
Chờ một xíu nhá. Chờ một xíu nhá. Đây
rồi.
Đâu nhở? Đây rồi.
Đây mình sẽ mình sẽ up cho bạn một cái
file Python. File Python bài tập về nhà
trông như thế này. Mình sẽ ghi vào file
Python như thế này. Đây
các bạn chờ tí mình đang mở ra nhá. Chờ
tí nó load một chút
không làm xong các bạn gửi cho mình. Các
bạn làm xong các bạn gửi cho mình mình
chữa cho các bạn nhá. Các bạn thấy đi m
hởng nó lag quá.
Đây để mình mở bằng à
đây nhá. Nó sẽ một cái file Python à nó
như thế này nhá. Nó sẽ có tám bài. Bảy
bài đầu thì basic thôi nhá. Mọi người
inbox cho mình trên Zalo nhá. Mọi người
inbox cho mình trên Zalo nhá. 7 B đầu
như này. Bảy bài đầu nó chỉ là làm tập
bài tập về list các thứ bình thường
thôi. Một là các bạn làm máy trên. Hai
là các bạn làm bài làm bài cuối. Cái bài
cuối này là bài mà ngày xưa hồi mình học
ở mình học ở tu môn có cái môn cấu trúc
rượu và thả nâng cao. Mình đây là bài
tập một trong những bài tập tuần của
mình. Đấy nó như thế này. Tức là bây giờ
ấy bài tập cuối này là gì? Tức là bây
giờ mình sẽ yêu cầu người dùng nhập vào
hai cái thư tiếng Anh là input đúng
không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ muốn tính ra
một cái chuỗi như này. Cái chuỗi nó quy
tắc như này. Tức là cái chuỗi này nó quy
tắc là gì? Là mỗi một từ trong cái chuỗi
này nó phải có ít nhất là ba ký tự đúng
không? Hai cái từ mà chúng ta nhập vào
từ bàn phím ý nó sẽ là cái từ đầu và từ
cuối của chuỗi. Và nó đảo quy tắc gì? Là
cái chuỗi này phải đảm bảo gì? Là hai
cái ký tự cuối của thứ trước nó phải là
hai ký tự đầu của của thứ sau. Được
chưa? Và các cái từ các cái từ của mình
đã được đấy sẽ lấy từ một cái file như
này đúng không? Và các bạn sẽ in mình ra
cái chuỗi nào nó ngắn nhất. Ví dụ ví dụ
đây đây một đây là một cái ví dụ đây ví
dụ như là người dùng họ nhập vào hai từ
là từ pen với từ paper đúng không thì
cái chuỗi ngắn nhất là gì là pen này
đúng không này đúng không các bạn không
n n n giống nhau này ch giống nhau này
pa giống nhau đúng không thì nó sẽ có vô
số chuỗi như này nhưng mà nó sẽ có những
cái chuỗi dài hơn chuỗi này ví dụ chuỗi
này chuỗi nó chỉ có bốn từ thôi còn
chuỗi khác nó có năm sáu từ thì mình
muốn các bạn in ra cho mình cái chuỗi
bốn cái chuỗi ngắn nhất là chuỗi bốn từ
đúng không nó có thể có nhiều hơn một
chuỗi ngắn nhất thì các bạn sẽ chỉ in ra
một trong số những chuỗi đấy thôi. Tức
là ví dụ các bạn có 10 cái chuỗi bốn từ
thì các bạn chỉ in một cái thôi đúng
không? Và ngắn hay dài là phụ thuộc vào
số của cái chuỗi đấy chứ không phụ thuộc
vào số ký tự nhá. Ví dụ là mỗi một từ
này nó dài 3 hay 4 năm không quan trọng
không quan trọng. Đây là cái chỗ này có
bốn từ. Được chưa? Đây là cái input
ngược lại paper với pen đúng không? Để
đảm bảo công bằng thì tất cả các từ các
bạn sẽ lấy trong cái danh sách này. Đây
danh sách các cái từ tiếng Anh được
chưa? Công bằng để cho đảm bảo cả lớp
làm giống nhau thì chúng ta sẽ lấy danh
sách các cái từ nó từ đây được chưa? Đấy
thì đấy là cái bài tập về nhà. Thì một
là các bạn làm làm bài cuối. Các bạn làm
làm bài cuối các bạn khỏi làm những bài
trên. Tại vì các bạn mà làm bài cuối thì
các bạn thừa sức làm những cái bài trên
đấy. Còn không thì các bạn làm bài bài
đầu cũng được nhá.
Đây là bài về lập trình đúng không thầy?
Python hay là về cái
>> Dạ vâng nó phải file Python đấy ạ. Đây.
Nó file Python. Nó là bài tập lập trình
về Python.
>> Có nghĩa là bài này là bài tập lập trình
Python.
>> Dạ. Dạ. Vâng. Tại vì suy cùng mình đến
lúc mình cũng phải mình cũng phải thực
hành á. về thực tự hành thì mình sẽ làm
qua những bài này để bài quen nhưng bài
đầu thì nó sẽ không chưa khó đâu. Những
bài đầu ti chưa khó mọi người có thể làm
những cái bài nếu mà mọi người thấy là
mình chưa quen lập trình các bạn có thể
bỏ bài cuối đi làm những bài trên thôi.
Đó
>> ờ mình muốn lập trình Python thì mình
phải dùng công cụ gì?
>> À ờ an tưởng quan nói rồi nhá mọi người
nhá. Với Python nó sẽ có hai công cụ một
là với bạn nào mà các bạn đang có hai
công cụ chính. Một là các bạn dùng Pham
Pam rất là đơn giản thôi. Pcham nhá
Cam đây. Pam ngày xưa nó chia làm hai
bản đây. Nó đã gộp là một rồi. Miễn phí
download. Cài xong các bạn dùng ờ Mac OS
hoặc các bạn dùng Windows các bạn đều
cài được vang nó lại như này. Đây chính
là cái cái mà mình vừa show các bạn đây.
Đây này. Ờ
đây cái
các bạn nhìn thấy đây này. Đây nó chính
là PAM đấy. Mình gõ code ở đây. Mình gõ
code ở đây. Đấy by cham như thế này. Cái
PAM này là các bạn chỉ dùng code Python
thôi. Nhưng mà đây là công cụ mình hay
dùng. Nên các bạn mà dùng PAM giống
giống như mình thì mình sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn mình sẽ hỗ trợ các bạn nó dễ hơn.
Còn hai là các bạn dùng VS Code. VS Code
thì nó cái ưu điểm nó sẽ code được nhiều
ngôn ngữ. Các bạn code cả VS Code này
các bạn sẽ dùng được nhiều ngôn ngữ
nhưng mà mỗi tội là gì? Mỗi tội là không
mỗi tội tức là cái này thì mình lại
không dùng nên là nếu mà các bạn có cái
trục chặc gì nó sẽ hơi khó cho mình để
mình giúp các bạn. Còn VS Code là có cái
ưu điểm là gì? Là code được nhiều ngôn
ngữ các bạn code cả Python cả C java
javascript thoải mái. Mình thì mình hơn
chục năm mình dùng P Cam rồi mình thấy
rất là ok. Nên bạn nào các bạn dùng các
bạn giống giống như mình hoặ là các bạn
dùng VS Code tùy nhá.
>> Trong VS Code mình phải cài thêm
extension của cái Python đúng không ạ? Ờ
hình như là cài luôn thì mình mình có
Python rồi thì phải hình như là code
Python mặc định được chứ chẳng qua là
mình có thêm một vài cái pack thêm thôi
thì mình phải cài thêm vào anh anh cứ
thử cài nếu mà nếu mà không code được
Pon thì mình cài sau nhưng mà em nhớ là
như là cài xong là có luôn thì phải.
>> Ok.
>> Dạ
>> có luôn rồi đó anh. Python có luôn cho
VS Code rồi đấy. Chỉ có một vài cái
library kiểu tùy vào chỗ của anh làm cần
thêm.
>> Đấy tức là những cái thứ mặc định basic
này thì thường nó có hết. Thế chẳng qua
là mình muốn thêm cái này thêm cái thêm
thư viện thì mình sẽ phải cài thêm thôi.
Nhưng mà với bài tập của mình, những bài
tập này thì các bạn chưa phải cài thêm
cái gì đâu. Toàn thư viện mặc định th
mà.
Bây giờ nó có một cái nữa mới ra là cái
antiravity ấy. Thì trong đấy nó cũng thế
đúng không? Cũng dùng để lập trình cũng
được đúng không? Không không. VS code và
phang thọ là IDE. ID IDE integrate
development environment.
Đúng
>> nó gọi là ID. ID nó là gì? ID nó là cái
chỗ để mình có thể code vào đấy
>> không đúng mình ý mình vừa rồi là Google
nó mới ra một cái là antigravity
>> à vâng đúng rồi nhưng mà antiravity nó
là cái nó là AI coding agent nó là cái
công cụ AI để nó hỗ trợ mình code chứ nó
không phải cái chỗ để mình gõ code vào
>> đấy nó là cái chỗ tức là ví dụ bây giờ
mình không biết code mình bảo nó code hộ
mình thì đấy là antiravity chứ nó không
phải là nó không phải nó nó không phải
là ID là cái nơi để mình gõ code vào.
>> Vâng. Đấy thì còn cái kia nó giống kiểu
close ấy. Nó giống kiểu close tức là nó
là nó là một nó là một con chatbot. một
con chot trên
>> nó cố cho mình chứ không phải để nơi để
mình tự.
>> Vâng đúng rồi. Nếu mà anh bảo nó là mày
code bài này nó sẽ cố hết mình chả làm
cái gì cả. Nhưng mà mình đang quay tr
quá trình học thì thì em muốn là mọi
người sẽ sẽ tự cố còn tất nhiên sau này
mọi người đi làm dùng thoải mái đi làm
antiquity nó rất là tốt luôn thì cực kỳ
tốt nhưng mà nó sẽ tốt khi mà mình đã có
được cái thức cơ bản rồi. Vâng.
Ok. Yeah.